はい それではよろしくお願いします
えっと あの 今日のテーマは親子関係についてでございます
うん で 親子 親と子の関係について
あの 最初に梵天から何とか出ているのかっていうことを紹介していきます
親って何ですかと ブラッマティビッカヴェ マーターピタロ エタンアディワチャナ
梵天とは あ これどう読む？父母
父母に使う同義語です
あの梵天っていうのは
あの 皆様どうするでしょうね
知らないんですかね あのブラマン教では一番上の神様なんですね
まあ絶対的な神様ですね
生命を造って管理するという
だから両親っていうのはお釈迦様が梵天だって言うんです
で 同義語だと まあかなりけなされてますね
バラモン教は どこかにいる絶対的な神様を拝むんじゃなくてね
自分を産んで育てて 作って育てる親が明確に
定義上梵天なんです すべて作って育てて面倒を見るのは神様だというならば
定義上親が梵天なんです
トゥッバーチャリアーティビッカヴェ マーターピトンナン エタンアディワチャナン
初師匠というのは一番ありがたい師匠なんですよ
それからどんな学問をしたっても
この最初に頭のレイアウトした人の影響を我々誰でも受けますよ
ですから 親っていうのは初初師匠なんですね
同義語です アウネイヤーティビッカヴェ マーターピトンナン エタンアディワチャナン
尊敬に値するもの 手を合わせて拝む
存在は誰ですか？誰に手を合わせて拝んでればいいんでしょうかという疑問があったらね
親を拝めという簡単なこと
意味なんです だから何の遠慮もなく
何の躊躇もなく もしかするとこの人はインチキ坊主ではないかとか
皆さん思ったりするでしょうに
あの坊主はだるしないとかね
そういうことを思いつつも
尊敬したり礼をしたりするとややこしいんですね
まあ気持ちよく誰かを尊敬したい
手を合わせたい 頭を下げたい
礼をしたいというならば
自分の親にしなさいということなんです
短期姿勢と この理由は何でしょうかと
えーと 親が子に耐給を与えるんですね
このバフカーラという言葉はなかなか直訳できないんですけど
これは自称で そのままもう単語を入れ替えただけなんです
もう無料にもう私たちのためにものすごい与えているんだっていう意味なんですね
バフカーラっていうのは
まあ養育者であり 私たちを育てたのはまあ親ですね
それからこの世を見せて
まあ教えてあげるんですね
私たちは赤ちゃんで何も知らなく生まれるんだけど
この世の中でこういうふうに生きるのだよと教えるのは親なんです
何から何まで教えてくれるんです
それで芸でそのまとめているんですね
ブラッマティマーターピタローボンバーチャリアティウンチャレ
アーウネイヤーチェプッターナンパジャヤアヌカンペカ
父母は梵天であります
初師匠だと言われる 言われる
子が礼拝すべきである
自分が作り出した生命を哀れも心配するのです
それから親孝行についてお釈迦様の教え
タスマーヒネーナメッセイエ サッカラエイエ パンディトアンネーナ アテパーネーナ ワッテーナ サヤネーナチェ
それを芸にしているのは
仏教とは そういうのは一応暗記しておくんです
ウッチャーデネーナーデーナパーダ
したがってですから 理性のある人は両親に来拝する
尊敬する食事 服装 住居を提供し
マッサージをしたり 体を洗ってあげたり
足を洗ったりするんです
まあ足を洗うと言ったっても
別の意味じゃなくて ただ足を洗うことなんです
具体的に 親から足を洗いましたではないんです
あのインドではね あの
一応インド文化っていうのは家具使わないんですね
床に座るんですね ですから
家に入ると足を洗わなくちゃいけないんです
親が外に出て家に戻ってくると
さっさと子が出て行って
水を持っていって足を洗ってあげる
これはすごい敬意を表すことなんです
お釈迦様は自分の足を自分で洗うんです
誰にも洗わせないんです
で 親の場合は 子がさっさと足を洗ってあげてくださいと
ターヤナンパリチャリアーエ マーターピトゥー スパンディター イデーヴァナン パサンサンティ ペッチャ サンゲー パモウダティ
偈を唱えるキーを忘れちゃったんです
理性のある人はこのように親のお世話をすること
この世で褒められるのです
いくら現代人の世界であっても
誰かがすごい自分の親のことを尊敬したり面倒見たりすると
みんな感動するんです
すごいと それって法則ですからね
だから世の中 世の世の中から自分が認められる存在になるんです
それから 親孝行する人は死後天国に生まれます
生まれて喜びを味わうのです
これはもう出典ですね
はい 次 別な経典 親孝行はどこまでやればいいかということです
これは結構省略しています
恩返ししきれない二人が
これブッダの言葉なんです
この世の中で二人がいるんですよ
いくら恩返ししたっても
まだやらなくちゃいけない
キリがないと ということは
向こうはうるさいという意味じゃなくて
それでも自分には借りがあるんです
借りは消えない いくら恩返ししても
それは母と父のことですと
もし 100年間も母と父を両肩に乗せて降ろすことなく
そのまま面倒を見てあげたとしても
恩返しし終わらないんです
これはたとえ話で もしもう寿命が長くて
お母さんとお父さんを自分の肩に乗せてあげて
そこで全部面倒見てあげると
寝ることも もう用を足すことも
体を洗うことも 何でもかんでも肩の上に載せたまんまでやってあげるんだと
百年間の でもまだ足りませんよと
この大地の千山祭山王の主として王にしてあげても
両親に恩返しをしたことにはならない
それよりもたくさんのことを親が自分にしてあげたのです
だからもうもう大地の王様にしてあげても
私は恩返ししまったよと
これはあり得ません 今はほんのちょこっとのことをやって
偉そうにね 親孝行しまったよとか思っているんですけど
お釈迦様の言葉で言えば
もうもう地球の戦災資産
自分好きなように使えるということで
王にしてあげても それでも親がもっとたくさんのことをあなたにしてあげたんだよと
まあはっきり言えば 私がここに何でいられるのかといえば
親のおかげでしょうに
だから命を与えたんだからね
これにかなわないでしょうに
だから私という存在は
もうどんなことをやっても
どんな偉くなっちゃっても
それ親のおかげなんです
ですからもう何しても恩返しできないんです
もしも人が信のない親に信サッダハですね
信じるものにするならば
道徳のない親を戒律を守る人にしてあげるならば
物惜しみで与えることを知らない親が施しをする人にしてあげるならば
無知の親が智慧のある人にしてあげるならば
親孝行をしたことになるんです
だから親孝行する方法があるんです
信っていうのは このまあ
精神的なことに興味あるということですね
ただ食ってもう寝ちゃえ
寝て死ねばいいやというね
まあ時々そういう親も我々にはいるんです
何もなく もうただ仕事をすることやら
金を儲けることやら 食べることやら
酒飲むことやら そのままごろにして寝る
寝て後で死んでしまう
これでいいやという まあどうにもならん親もいますよ
その親に まあ精神のことも考えてくださいと
いうことを教えてあげることができれば
親がそれ やっぱりもっと真面目な人間にならなくちゃいけないと思ってくれたら
もう親孝行したことになります
まあ時々ね もっとものすごい犯罪もしたり
道徳はひとかけらもなくて
もう悪いことばっかりしている親もいますよ
しかし 悪いことを社会に悪いことを不正を働かせて
いろんなことをして金を儲けてきて
でも家族を養っているんです
子供を育てるんです だから
うちの親は犯罪もするんだとかね
あいつは誰が親者かって
そんな言う権利がないんです
うちの親が強盗してでも強盗することは社会的な犯罪ですけど
その財産を持ってきて子供に食べさせるんです
だから子供にとっては
これはなおさら申し訳ないということになるんです
私たちを育てるために犯罪までやっているんだよと
だから現代人がね 自分の親がもう本当に悪人でだらしないとかね
あんな親はなんで尊敬しなくちゃいかんですかとかね
あいつでそんな親がいらんやとかね
でもこれはもうちょっと論理違います
だからやっぱり自分を育てたんです
ですから まあそういう道徳を教えてあげたり
あるいは親がけちんぼで何一つも誰にもあげない
他人の面倒は全く見ない性格であっても
家族は養っているはずなんです
母親は子供の面倒は見ているはずなんです
子供にもお参りにもご飯あげませんよということは全くありえないんです
ですから その場合は 自分が大人になってからはね
こんなケチな人生はね
あまり良くないんだよと
みんなに嫌われますよと
だから社会の人々にもいろいろ協力してあげたり
貢献してあげたりした方がいいんじゃないんですかというふうに
そのことを教えてあげることができて
親もやっぱりせっかく息子が娘が言うんだからね
まあこれから頑張ってみようということになったならば
もう親孝行したことになるんです
それから 智慧のない 真理の知らない人々に
まあその真理を教えてあげる
それを理解するならば
親が理解するならば 親孝行したことになります
真理といっても 世の中で誰も真理を語ってない
全部嘘ばっかしですから
世の中はね 真理というのはブッダが語った教えになるんです
これは専門用語で言えば
サッダハシーラ チャガ
パンニャーという つのカテゴリーなんです
親にサッダシーレチャガパンニャというつを教えてあげることができれば
親孝行したということになります
はい それで正しい親孝行
いわゆる完全に恩返しになる親孝行って何ですか？というサッダシーラ
チャガパンニャーです
それを教えてあげなくちゃいけないんです
あの時々私にもいろいろ質問
疑問を持ってくる人々がいますけどね
お父さんにも仏教の本とか禅の本当かあげますけど
まるっきり読む気はないんだけど
どうすればいいかとかね
で 瞑想しなさいと言ったところで怒られたとかね
で そこは自分がちょっと調子に乗ってるだけなんですね
親は礼拝する対象だからね
あんたこれ勉強したらどうでしょうか？と言ったら
これは失礼いいところでしょうに
だからとても尊い偉い方に何か言う態度を壊さなくちゃあかんですよ
だからその気持ちがあって
親は尊敬に値する対象で
もう全く何の疑問もなく
何の躊躇もなく土下座して頭を下げて礼をするべき対象です
その人に 態度でっかくでね
喋るとそれは聞いてくれないでしょうに
だから親にものを言う時の我々の言い方がまずくて
結構テーラワーダ仏教を学んでいる方々は
やっぱり経典によって親にも教えたくなるんです
親のことを心配して だから気持ちははっきりわかります
私も 親孝行したいというね
もう年もとって ほとんどもう一か所でどこにも行かない
行かれない状態にいると心配でたまらないんだから
なんか心清らかになることでも教えてあげようかという
子供の気持ちは正しいんだけど
親と喋る時 言葉使いはものすごい気をつけなくちゃいけないんです
このこれ気持ちでわかります
親を尊敬しているか 馬鹿にしているかという
ですから まあそこは余談で
この人は誰でも東西南北上下という六方に囲まれて生きています
人間というのは 物体物理的に見れば
どこにいても自分には東西南北上下あります
逃げられませんね どこにいても六方に我々は囲まれているんです
そのように  6種類の いわゆる避けられない人間関係が世にあるんです
逃げられません 六方から逃げられないと同じく
我々には 6種類の人間関係があるんです
六方に例えて理解しなくちゃいけないんですよ
マーターピターディサプッバチャリヤダ
キナディサプットダラディサパンチャミッタマッチャチョンタラ
ダサカッマカラヘッタウッダンサマナブラフマナ
エターディサナマッセイアアルマトークーレギ
で 全部訳してないんです
両親は東 師匠は南 家族は西
家族というのは奥さんやら子供っていう
あの現代的に家族という意味ではなくて
友達は北 使用人は下 シャモンバラモンは上の方で
これはあの東から始めて時計回りで言ってるんです
で 上はシャモンバラモンっていうのは当時インドではあのの宗教家ですね
尊敬するところ だから時代によってそれはまあ変えても構わない
そういうふうに我々にはこの6種類の関係があります
これがないではないんです
私にはないとかね 例えば宗教的なことはまるっきり無関心で生きている人もいますね
人生はもうガタガタになるんです
無宗教で無神論者で構わないんだけど
道徳的に自分の心を導く何かが必要なんです
悪をやめて善行為をするような何かのガイドラインが人間には欠かせないんです
だから無神論者あれやこれやと言っても
そんなのはあくまでも知識的な問題で
知識的には無神論者で一向に構わない
知識的には特定の信仰がないんだよというのは一向に構わないんだけど
道徳的な生き方は否定することはできないんです
特にこれ アメリカではね
このエティストというこの無神論者たちがいるんです
結構 ヨーロッパでも 彼らが一般のアメリカ人よりはもう桁違い
知識人なんです ものすごい頭がいいんです
しかし もう徹底した宗教家たちよりもものすごい道徳的なんです
しかし 神なんかはひとっかけらも信じません
むちゃくちゃバカにするんです
しかし 彼らが神をバカにしながら何を言うのかというと
もっと我々は人間で 物事を考えて判断して
良い道徳のある人間で生きていなくちゃいけないんだと
神がいると信じること自体が迷惑やという態度で語ってますから
だから問題ないんです
無神論者で ということで
日本でもね あまり特定の信仰は私にありませんという人々は結構いますけど
人間なら何か精神的に自分を導く
何か考え方 生き方がこれ欠かせないんです
それなくなったらとんでもない悪人になるだけ
それでまあ 平等な親子
親子の義務 で この6種類の関係について今日は喋りません
本も出してますからね
シガーローワードっていうお釈迦様はなんとか在家の人に教えてほしいというふうに本を出しているし
そちらで詳しく書いてある可能性あります
で 一応お釈迦様が親の義務から始まります
だから人に喋ってるんだからね
その人は誰かの子供だからね
だから自分の義務から教えを始まります
親の義務 子供の義務は 5つです
1自分が養ってもらったので親を養う
2親の仕事 義務 責任などを代わりに果たす
親が衰えていくと まあ親がやってきたいろいろ責任やら義務やら
そういうのはまあ親の代わりに言ってやってあげる
3家 家っていうのは 家柄とかね
家族ですね その家を継承してあげる
時々親がそれも期待するんです
まあ我々は歴史の長い家であって
まあなんとかなんとかとかね
しなくちゃとかね それはまあ親の期待でもあって
その伝統やらね 家のしきたり
習慣から家柄を守ってあげる
継続してあげる 親の財産を管理する
親が他界した時 供養するというところですね
親の財産管理するんじゃなくて破壊するっていう現代人ですからね
で  その 5つは子供の義務
それで親の義務もまた 5つあります
自分が親として 1悪をやめ
やめさせること 2善をやらせる 3
教育をさせる 4 適した相手と結婚させる 5
時期を見て財産を与える
という 5つです それは親の義務
そこで この親の義務っていうのはほとんど世の中で行っていますよ
だって どんな親でも子供にこれはダメ
これはダメ これはやってはいけないと教えているでしょうね
乱暴な言葉を使うなよとかね
言葉汚いとかね それからちゃんと挨拶しなさいとか
あれやこれやと悪いことをやめさせて良いことをさせるということは
どんな親でもまあ自分にできる範囲ではやっているんです
しかし 子が自分の義務をさぼっているんですね
問題は 自分が子供として親に対する義務になってくると
ほとんどさぼっているんです
だからお釈迦様が子供の義務で教え始めたんです
教えの順番で よくこの中身を考えてみてくれ
お釈迦様がおっしゃっている中身がすごい
ごく当たり前の中身なんです
親は子供に悪いことをやめなさいと
どうせどんな国の親でも言ってるし
いいことをしなさいと
どんな国の親でも一応言ってるし
教育させることはね どんな親でも子供に教育させてあげたいし
経済的な状態 社会で戦争とかなんとかあったりしてできなくなっても悩むんですね
この子には何も教えることはできない
教えてあげることはできませんでしたと
学校に行かせることはできませんでしたと
親はすごく悩むんです
ですから 親の義務はだいたい果たしてます
問題はこうなんですよ
自分の義務を果たさないんです
はい これから今日のテーマに入ります
一応仏典にあるものは全部教えましたからね
話を聞きたくないと思うならば
今がチャンス もうブッダの話をもう全部終わりました
全部じゃなくて またありますけど
大事なポイントをね これから現代的に分析してみます
はい これはまあ発表されているテーマですね
切れないと 切ったと思っても感情的には切れない絆です
この親子関係っていうのは切れないもんです
愛情の関係が切れたら
争惑の関係が現れるんです
例えば 親が子にはもうもう嫌になっちゃって
もう出て行けと勘当したっても
関係はそのままなんです
勘当なんかできないんです
それでも親 親 子がいろんな悪いことしていると
それでも怒って もう腹が立って
もう勘当しちゃったんだから忘れちゃえばいいのに
忘れられませんね そこで子供が親を捨ててしまっても
それから親を憎むことになるんです
憎むことも結局は関係あるんだからなんです
関係ないん 憎む必要ないでしょ
だから愛情の絆か憎悪の絆か
切れないんです 生きる苦しみのおまけですね
これが 我々は生きてるとこれが必ずおまけで出てくるんです
はい それから遺伝子と親っていうところで
で 動物の場合は遺伝子だけの関係です
子が独立したら忘れるんです
動物もものすごい真剣に子育てするんです
すごい真剣です もう狂暴で命かけて子供は育てます
全然説教は聞いてないんです
人間よりははるかに完璧に子育てをするんです
もうほとんど失敗しないんです
動物の場合 失敗するのは動物園にいる動物だけなんです
いわゆる人間に飼われて面倒を見てもらっている動物たちは
時々育児放棄とかします
自然の中の動物はこれは絶対しないんです
しっかり育てる それから失敗しちゃったと
うちの子はというのはないんです
これがなんでそんな見事にできますかって
これ 遺伝子ですね だから
この遺伝子がどうしても自分の遺伝子を続けて持っていきたいという
すごく利己主義な遺伝子だからね
えらい利己的ですね とてもセルフィッシュ
本がありますから セルフィッシュジーンというね
それは生物学者が書いてるもんで
だから遺伝子が自分が生き続けたいんだから
もうからくりやってるんです
思考 感情 知識 職業などの複雑な関係があるので
人間はこのことを忘れられない
で 動物の場合は 子供が独立したところで追い出すんです
それから忘れるんです
自分の子供だと 見事に忘れるんです
それで関係切られているんです
仕事終わったらはい 終わった
さようならと これが人間にはできないんです
動物はもう子供が独り立ちしたら
もうそれからはもう知らない
人間だけ なんで子供が独立しても
もう大人になっても なかなかもう愛情だけは消えない
忘れることはできない
私に子供がいたっけとかね
これはありえないんですね
人がおめかし あ そういえばもしかすると産んだかもしれませんとかね
これはありえないでしょ
まあ極度に痴呆にならない限りは
我が子は忘れられませんね
その理由は 人間に思考がある
激しい感情がある いろいろなことがあります
遺伝子が働くので 人間にも子が生まれたら育たすことができます
人間でも子供が生まれたらもうたちまち親になるんです
時々女の子なんか男の見たても
こいつらしい やばいなとかね
もうこんなわがままでいい加減でどうしようかと
しかし 子供が言われたら
突然 もう瞬時に親に変わっちゃうんですね
今までの性格はどこへ行ったか
もうさっぱりわからないんです
子供が生まれたら 両親がどんなわがまま
いい加減乱暴でいたっても
もう子供が生まれた瞬間でもうもう変わっているんです
それが遺伝子ですね はい
ここに愛着を持つ 愛着も遺伝子の仕業で
新しい命に対して強い愛着が生じるんです
そこで私たちには もう自分が死んでも育てなくちゃいけないという
なんかすごい感情が生まれてくるんです
あれは大したことないんだ
あれは遺伝子の働きなんです
遺伝子が自分の遺伝子が切れるのは嫌なんです
だから単純に遺伝子が自分だけ続けたい
他どうなってもいいんです
ですから この遺伝子が体の中で変化を起こして
強烈な愛着を作ってあげるんです
うん それから大事に命かけて育てるんです
例えばね 子供が生まれたら
なんかすごい幸福感が生まれて
充実感が生まれてきて
生まれてきて もう全然大変なのに
子育てはね ものすごい苦しい作業なんですよ
なのにこれ喜んでやってるんですね
なんて楽しいでしょうか
とか 自分の命はもういつでももう後回しにする
後回しにして 子供の命は大事にする
これは生命の法則とは違うんです
生命の法則というのは
自分の命を大事にすることなんです
しかし 遺伝子にはそんなあんた死んじゃってもどうでもいいやとということで
新しい命を作りなさいよと
そこで新しい命が出てきて
そこは独り立ちするまで
自分たちがなんかもう興奮しちゃって
感情が生まれちゃって
必死で子供を育てるんです
子供は独立して一人前になると
自分がボロボロ もうどうにもならん
それから自分の命は遺伝子守ってくれないんです
ものすごい勢いで老化させちゃうんです
衰えるんです もうあなたの用が済みましたと
だから 遺伝子が我々を道具扱いしているんです
用が済んだら捨てると
道具はって言ったら なんかもう紙カップやらね
そんな状態で我々は扱っているんです
紙カップは使うまでは大事にするんです
使ったところで もうポイとゴミ箱に捨てるんです
割り箸も使うまでは大事にするんです
使ったところで もう終わり
もう捨てちゃいます そんな感じですよ
だから この子供に対する愛着っていうのは
遺伝子のからくりなんです
人間が愛着を覚えるので
成長した子を捨てることができないんです
これって人間だけ この知識
感情 いろいろあるんだから
この愛着を覚えてるんです
いらんことは忘れましょうということを人間にできないんです
いらんことに限って忘れられません
必要なものならすぐ忘れるんです
そういう人間だからね
動物は忘れます 子供のこと
そこで動物と同じ 我々は遺伝子の奴隷で
もう子育てしますけど
子供が大きくなってきても
あの楽しみ あの快楽感
あの至福感を覚えているんです
覚えて まだまだ子供を追っかけていって
なんとか執着してやろうと思っちゃうんです
逃がしてあげないんです
愛着と体 遺伝子の働きによる愛着は物質的なものです
ホルモンなどの物質を作って
脳体を管理するわけ で
子供が生まれたら愛着
愛着が生まれるということは
これは物質医学的に証明できるものです
脳が変化を起こすんです
いまだなかったホルモンが新しく生まれるんです
だって子供が生まれたらすぐ女性のおっぱいが出ますから
ずっとおっぱいが出ちゃうと
これ困ったもんでしょうね
そこでおっぱいの中身も子供の成長とともに変わるでしょ
だから世の中でね 誰でも言ってることでしょうね
赤ちゃんにとってはもう母乳には勝てるものは作れません
いくらフォーミュラとかなんとか飲ませたっても
母乳には勝てっこはないんです
母乳はその生まれた子供に特別作った
栄養なんです それも産んだ母親の母乳だったら
まあ別な母親がおっぱいあげてもいいんだけど
ちょっと時間のずれが出てくるんですね
別の人間ですからね 他の人のおっぱい吸ったってもね
まあ子供は吸いますからね
全然めっちゃで構わないんだけど
他人の子供の場合はこの時間のずれが当然ありますね
産んだ母親はそうじゃなくて
その日からおっぱいあげてるんだから
子供の成長にぴったし適した母乳が出てくるんです
中身が変わって変わって
だから それによって愛情が生まれてきて
これは脳のいろんな物質が新しいものが生まれたりするし
体も変わったりするし
そういうことだから この遺伝子の愛着っていうのは物質的なものです
そんなに気にする必要はないんです
ちょっと酒飲んだような感じで
酒が体にある間はまあ頭がおかしくなるだけで
体から出ていったらもう何のこともないんです
そんなもんなんですね
そこで酒に例えてみると
我々は激しい二日酔いで
二日酔いというか もうそれからずっと苦しむんですね
で 酒飲んだ人も 自分の体が早く酒を分解して
この体から出さない 外へ出さない限りは
かなり体に悪いんですね
で 愛着も同じで この時は興奮するのは構わないんだけど
適当な時間でそこは物質を分解して体から出さなくちゃいけないんです
私たちは子供を子育てで悩んでるんだっていうことは
二日酔いで困ってるんだということなんです
二日酔いはかなりも厳しくて長持ちしているんだと
子供を産んでも体にホルモンが生まれないと子育てを放棄するんです
だから この親子の子供に対する愛着っていうのは
この物質ですから 時々
自分が産んだ子供なのに育てないというケースが出てくるんです
人間にもあります おっぱいは出てこない
子供見たってのは可愛いと思えない
もう触りたくもない それは理由 2つあります
あとで説明しますけど
一つはこの脳が変化していない
妊娠している間でも必要な変化が体に起きていない
遺伝子に何か問題があるんです
ですから 必要な幸福感を感じるホルモンとかは出てきていないんです
それはありえます それから
自分で産まなくても 我々はもう遺伝子ができていますから
他人の子供に対しても我が子のように愛着を作ることもできます
それはもう至って簡単に
人間の世界で起こることで
人の子供なのに ちょっとちょっと面倒見たところでもう忘れられなくなっちゃうし
また心配してしまっちゃうし
これはこの決まって男性の方が結構あると思います
しかし 男性は子供を産むことをしませんだからね
男性のホルモンは この我が子やと思うことで
触ることで 抱っこしてあげることで
寝かしてあげることで
頭が変化してホルモンが出てくるんです
ですから この 男性の場合はそのパターンなんです
女性の場合はやっぱり産みますから
妊娠したところで脳が変化していくんです
この幼稚園とかね そういう小学校の時とかね
なんで子供は男の先生の方にすーっとぶら下がっているとわかってます
理解してますかね だいたいそれは女性の仕事にしていますけどね
幼稚園でお子さん一人男がいたら
子供はその人の周りなんです
理由は この女の人にとってはちょっとハンディがあるんです
自分が産んだ子供に愛着はあるんですけど
他人の場合はもう憎しみも起これます
敵視することもできます
男の場合はどうしても見て触って愛着が生まれるんだから
見たもの触ったものに対しては
もう大事にしなくちゃ
遊ばなくちゃという気持ちが生まれているんです
これは子供はよく知っているんです
だから子供は相手が男だったら自分ってかわいいでしょと一生懸命自分を売り込むんです
そこで向こう側もやっぱりかわいいな
こいつはと思ったら もう脳がもうそこから変化し始めるんです
体から独立する愛着 心
感情 思考 妄想 知識などが働くと
体と関係なく愛着が流れ出します
そこで人間の問題は もう思考とかいろいろありますからね
妄想もしますから だから思考妄想すると
あの愛着がまたまた生まれて生まれて生まれていくんです
それは遺伝子と関係なくなっちゃうんです
遺伝子が作るホルモンは適切な時期で消えます
これはもうどうしようもないんです
女性には子供を産める能力っていうのはもう決まってますね
何歳までかということは
それ終わったらもう子供は産めないんですね
そのようになりますから
遺伝子の場合はちゃんと自動的になくなります
が 我々には知識があるわ
妄想があるわ 感情があるわ
考えることはできるんだから
最悪 あの愛着をもう再生するんです
感情を再生すると また体が変化するんです
人間に他人の子供を 子供を育てることができます
ですから 人間には他人の子供を育てられます
動物にはちょっと期待しにくいんです
食べられるかもしれません
他の同じ種類であってもね
で この子育てなさいと言われたところで
すぐパクッと食べられる可能性も
人間はそれやらないんですね
もうもう 100万人に一人ぐらいやるかもしれませんだけど
仏はやりませんよ 人間というのは子供を見た途端
もうそれだけでもう変わるんです
子供を大事にしよう 守ってあげようとするんです
たまに動物も犬が猫におっぱいをあげるなどね
同じ行動をします たまに哺乳類の動物はたまにあります
まあいいや しょうがない
今育ちます 育ててあげますよとかね
で 犬が子供を産んで 例えばもう親が亡くなった猫の赤ちゃんが見たら
まあおっぱいあげたりする
舐めてあげたり 面倒見たりはします
はい それからこの親子関係で問題っていうのは
この精神的な愛着なんです
医学的な愛着はもう全然問題ないんで
それはもうそのうち消えますから
思考妄想で作る愛着が問題を起こすんです
精神的な愛着は 思考 妄想
知識 感情がある限り増幅したり
変化したり ねじれたりする
これが問題なんです 愛着が生まれて
それから思考でこれをかき回すでしょ
妄想でかき回すと増幅する可能性もあります
あるいは消えてしまう可能性もあります
あるいは怒り 憎しみに変わる可能性もあります
あるいは変にもうねじられて
この愛着って何やと この親子関係って何なのかという
問題になる場合もあります
すごい社会でそういう問題があります
アメリカでもよくケース聞きますけど
あの親に子供が暴行させるとかね
で 献身相関というかね
こういうことは起こってしまうんですね
初めは自分の子供から可愛い可愛い可愛いと思っていて
子供がちょこちょこ大きくなってくると
この愛着が別に欲に変わってしまっちゃって
大変なことになります
だからそういうトラブルが起こります
愛は憎しみにも変わります
だから親が子供を殺したり
子供が親が子供を殺したり
あり得るんです 人間の社会ではあり得ます
精神的愛着により子育ての問題が起こるんです
ですから 愛着 2つあると考えておいてください
遺伝子から出てくるホルモン的な愛着と
頭で考えて感情で作り出す愛着
問題を作るのは この頭で
感情で 妄想で作る愛着なんです
それでブッダの真理に基づいて説明します
道徳の成立と問題の解決
では どのようにこの問題を解決しますかと
体が遺伝子の道具にならないこと
これが道徳になるんです
人は輪廻転生しているんです
死にたくないんです 体の快楽に依存しているんです
それであのあの利己主義遺伝子という本を書いた生物学者もいますけど
彼らがわからないところ
科学者は輪廻のことなんです
輪廻の話と遺伝子の話はあまり合致しません
我々は遺伝子だけで生きているならば
なんで死にたくないと思うんですかね
衰えれば死ななくちゃいけないでしょうに
死にたくないんです 遺伝子にしてみれば
自然作ったらはい さようならなんです
だから 遺伝子的に我々は年取って衰えて
食欲もなくなって 生きる気力もなくなって
もう死にます 動物は年取っていくとやはり死にますからね
しかし この輪廻というものがあるんだからね
輪廻するのは心なんですね
遺伝子じゃないんです
心は死にたくないと思っているんです
だから我々は年取っても死にたくないんです
生きようと頑張るんです
それが遺伝子の命令じゃないんです
それから私たち失敗するところが
肉体を持った瞬間から肉体に依存するんです
それで遺伝子に負けてしまうんです
肉体から得る快楽で心を刺激させて生きるエネルギーを作るんです
体の奴隷になっているんです
だからもう私たちは体の奴隷なんです
生き続けたいという必死な思いで行為を選択はしません
体の奴隷だから 我々は行為の選択しません
難しい言葉ですけど 快楽であれば何でもやります
楽しければ何でもやりますでしょ
それはどんな人間もそうなんです
自分が興奮するならば
刺激が生まれるならば
いいかどうかは考えたことはないんです
やっちゃいます だから選択しないんですよ
遺伝子の体の奴隷だから
だから食べ過ぎもあるし
遊び過ぎもあるし アル中も出てくるし
麻薬中毒も出てくるし
ゲーム中毒も出てくるし
いろんなものに中毒する
子供を車にそのまま置いておいて
赤ちゃんをね パチンコに行く
で パチンコやって帰ってくると子供は死んでいるとかね
そういうニュースあるでしょうに
それがこの体の奴隷になっているんです
肉体に刺激を与えたいんです
ですから 我々は遺伝子の奴隷である限り
行為を選択しない その時はただ生き続けたいだけで
生き続けるための刺激が欲しい
だから怖いものから逃げます
楽しいもの 刺激を与えるものだったら飛んでやります
それだけの生き方なんです
だから道徳は成り立ってないんです
感情に負けないことは倫理ですね
他を殺しても生きていきたい
生命は 嘘ついてでも身を守りたい
一つ書き忘れちゃったんですけど
結果を変えられず快楽にふけりたいですね
などの生き方が体の奴隷になっていることです
体が壊れると知っていても
酒飲む人は酒飲みます
楽しいと これなくなったら
私にとっては何も面白いことがないんだぞと
日本です 自分の楽しみだと
これだと やっぱりそこで奴隷になっていて判断はしない
判断できない 殺さない
嘘つけないなどの生き方が革命的で倫理道徳になります
そこで仏教で語っている殺してはならないということは
我々の遺伝子の命令じゃないんです
感情の命令じゃないんです
この奴隷でいる我々は
この鎖を破ろうとしているんです
そこが道徳なんです 革命的に攻撃してみなさいよ
だから誰でも他人を殺しても構わないという遺伝子の奴隷なんです
人間殺してはならんというもういい加減な話あるんですけど
自己防衛を防衛ためなら構わないと言うんです
魚殺すことは これは正しい行為になっているんです
動物を殺すことも正しい行為になっているんです
ですから この道徳倫理っていうのは結構かなり微妙なものなんです
我々はこの遺伝子の命令にちょっと攻撃してみるんです
感情の命令にちょっと逆らってみるんです
それで自分で行為を判断するんです
やるかやらないかと 例えば
気持ちが嘘をつきなさいと言ってるんです
自分の遺伝子も嘘をつきなさいよと言ってるんです
その方がお前の利益になるんだよと
そこでその命令に逆らって嘘をつかないことにするんです
それが道徳なんです 特別なことをしたんです
これがエネルギーになりますよ
それが生きる生命の幸福になる原因になりますとお釈迦様説くんです
そのまま感情のままで生きていても
不幸になるだけ 奴隷には不幸ないでしょうに
奴隷っていうのは 字通りの奴隷で
自分の命にも何の権利もないんです
奴隷を預かっている人がのやりたい放題
激流に溺れないで 仏道は感情の輪廻の激流に溺れないで
解脱という安全な境地にたどることです
そこでこの感情の流れに浸って生きるんじゃなくて
反対に攻撃して打ち勝つことは仏道なんです
それはお釈迦様が解脱
涅槃という言葉で教えているんです
輪廻を脱出すると 存在を脱出すると
存在を肯定するんじゃないんです
革命的な生き方ですが
ただ逆らえばよしではなく
理性と因果法則に合わせて丹念に計画を立てるんです
逆らえばいいという単純な話じゃないんです
法則を理解して 生命とは何かと
心とは何かと 感情とは何かと
こいつらの奴隷にはなりませんよと
で 論理的に逆らってみる
計画的に よく私に昔も言われたことがありまして
我々はもう結婚しないし
もうそういう そういう関係の仕事は一切やらない
あなた方は悪いことをやってるんだと
これ 日本の宗教の方々に言われるんですね
人間なら子供を作らなくちゃあかんでしょうにと
あなた方の考えだったら
もう世の中人間なくなっているんだよ
なくなってしまいますよと
よくえらい論言ってるつもりなんですけど
しかし そこまでぐうたらな話するとね
相手にする必要ないんだから
私は まあまあそう言ったってもと言って
まあ一応ごまかしますけど
あんまりにもヘリクツで
世界から人間がなくなっちゃうんだからといって
別に別にどうってことないでしょうに
どうやって必ずしも地球に人間がいなくちゃいけないと証明するんですかね
まだ誰か誰かが結婚していないんだと言ったっても
人類はなくなるわけでもないでしょうに
感情の奴隷っていくらでもいるんだから
いくらでも子供を作りますよ
世の中で で 私が言いたいのは
あなた方は感情で子供を作るんだけど
子供を心配することはできないでしょうにと
だから子供がない私たちはもっと心配するんだよと
誰の子供であっても だから私になれたら
もう子供はどんな子供でも
まあまあ お母さん こっちおいでって
私はこっちおいでって
わしのところに来るんだから
何ですか それは すごく心配するんですね
素直に命を 愛情 愛着じゃないんです
ですから ただ逆らえばいいわけじゃなくて
丹念に法則を理解して
丹念に計画を立てて この輪廻の流れに
感情の流れに逆らってみるんです
武道はそういうふうにできているものなんです
だから 皆様の理屈は全然もうもうもう受け取りましたと言っても
それはまあその資格もないんです
まあ考えてみますという
まあ例えばね まあよく言うでしょ
まあ日本の社会では やっぱり人間関係では酒飲むことはとても大事なことであると
仕事終わったら一杯飲まなきゃ
もうみんな仲良くできないでしょうにと
だから仏教の 5回目の戒律はね
これは現代では適用できませんと
適用できませんと まあ反論出てくるでしょうね
真面目な反論やと それは一度も考えたこともないんです
ただ 世の中の儀礼 儀礼もありますから
答えますけど 私にとってはなんだこの質問かいという気持ちなんです
ということは 会社で仕事をしても
長い時間お互い仲良くすることはできなかったという話でしょう
それで頭イカれた時だけ仲良くすることはできますからね
それ人間関係ですかね
お互いに心配する関係ですかね
それが だから相当イカれてるでしょ
人間関係と 24時間の関係でしょうに
8時間ぐらい一緒に仕事したならば
その間で気づくことでしょうに
電車に乗ったらその人間関係で
会社に行ったらそちらの人間関係で
家に戻ったらそちらの人間関係で
友達の家に行ったらそちらの人間関係で
酔っ払う 酔っ払わなきゃできないんだというならば
よく言うんですね そういう質問は
ですから 仏教でダメと言ったらダメだと決めてください
もうバカになりますよ
でなきゃ まあ私はあまり馬鹿にしてないんだからといって
賢い質問をしたということになりません
ブッダがダメと言ったらダメなんです
もう宇宙の全法則を見て
このようにしてくださいと言ってるんだからね
そういうことで 私たちはすべて理解する必要はないんです
お釈迦様全部知り尽くして語ってるんだから
ものすごいものの見事にこのもう教えられてるんです
ただ 我々は出家がなんで出家すると最初の約束はもう性行為をやめることなんです
その時点で体にある遺伝子にお前の話聞かないんだよっていうことになってるでしょうに
私たちは精神的に別なことに挑戦するんだよと
で 面白いことは性行為しなくても生きていられますね
病気にならないんです
じゃあ呼吸しない しなかったら死ぬでしょ
で 帰る必要はないでしょ
人間は呼吸するなかしてはいけないとか
ご飯食べてはいけませんとかないでしょ
それはないんです お釈迦様はこれはやめなさい
言ったことをやめたっても死にはしませんし
かえってすごい健康で幸福になります
酒 麻薬は使うのはやめなさいと
こんなこと面倒くさいんだと
これは大変な反社会的な教えだとよく言うんですよ
酒 麻薬を使うことが反社会的でしょうに
ですから ただ逆らえばいいわけじゃなくて
ちゃんと計画的に遺伝子の奴隷にならない
感情の奴隷にならないということをしなくちゃいけないんです
これが仏道 これが仏教が語る禅ですね
意欲を道徳行為にする
それで意欲っていうのは奴隷行為ですね
奴隷だからやらなくちゃいけないんです
奴隷制度は皆様が拝んでる国がありますね
アメリカと昔あったでしょう
には勉強してください
奴隷の状況はどうなったかと
奴隷にはもう何の権利もない
朝から晩まで仕事をする
で どこか何かもう小屋作って
そこで横になるだけで寝るものは用意してない
病気になっても治療しない
それでも仕事をしろと言うんです
病気になって倒れていたら
お前仕事してないだろ
今日はご飯ないんだよということになっちゃうんです
逃げたら捕まるんです
逃げてる奴隷を見つけた人が
元の主人のところに戻してあげなくちゃいけないんです
アメリカはその奴隷制度を頑固と守ろうとしていたんです
そこをやめたことで アメリカ人ってすごいいいですねというのは
どういうわけかよくわかりませんだけど
人を殺した人 私は人を殺すことをやめますと
素晴らしいですね あなたはと人を一度も殺したことない人はダメになっちゃうんですね
この屁理屈によく乗るんでしょ
だからそれでも奴隷制度なくなったことで
その人々の命も危うい状態になったでしょうに
だから奴隷っていうのはそんなもんで
逃げることもできないし
文句言うこともできないし
権利を言うこともできないし
だから子供を産んだお母さんが人間だから疲れますよ
寝なくちゃいけないでしょうに
じゃあ赤ちゃんが生まれたらどうします？寝る
これで寝ることじゃなくて
もう 1時間ごとでしたっけ？もうもう何回おっぱいあげますかと
朝 3時であろうか もうまたおっぱいあげなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうでしょう
大体 1 年間ほとんど寝てないでしょう
ご飯食べてる時でも これギャーッと泣くかどうかわからないし
便所に行ったっても落ち着いてその仕事できないし
それ見事にもう奴隷になってるでしょ
その時間間では しかし
その意欲も道徳行為に入れ替えることできます
人間の日常生活そのものが道徳的な行為に変えることができます
前に述べたように 感情の奴隷にならないことに挑戦するんです
感情の奴隷にならない
ただそれだけ 意欲は遺伝子の命令と感情の衝動で行いますので
善行為ではありません
この意欲は善行為じゃないんです
私は献身的に子供を育てたんだからといってね
何の得にもならないんだ
そんなのはどうしようも何の得にもならないでしょ
大きくなったら出てきますからね
子育ては善行為であるならば
昆虫でも徳を積んでいることになります
子供を育てていることはとても素晴らしいことであって
素晴らしい善行為だというならば
昆虫もやっていますけどね
ネズミもやっていますからね
大変善人ですね 善人ですね
善行為しているんだから
こんなの話にならないんです
これ人間にできることなんです
遺伝子を管理することは個人にはできません
これよく覚えてください
私たちに私たちの遺伝子管理はできないんです
例えば 反抗期になる子供に
あんたね 反抗期にならないでくださいと
これはちょっと親が困っているんだよと
学校の先生も困っているんだ
それを言っても聞いてくれるんですかね
その時期になったら反抗するんです
これは遺伝子のからくりなんです
それは管理できないんです
しかし 遺伝子が作り出す感情を管理できます
例えば 男の子がかなり反抗期になったところで
もう他人に教えられますよ
まああんたの気持ちはわかりますけども
もう思春期で もうもう体力もあってね
まあ親いうことは聞きたくなったりするかもしれませんだけど
もうちょっと落ち着けと
で 別にまあまあ外で友達と遊んだりとか
いろいろなことをしてね
まあ親にあまり逆らわない方がいいんじゃないですかと
そういうふうに教えてあげることはできます
教えてあげれば 本人もああ
そういえばですねと思って
いくらか自分の気持ちをね
管理しようとする 気持ちは管理したんだけど
体の変化はそのまま起きてるんです
我が子のためなら死にも死も惜しまないなどの気持ちは
奴になっている証拠です
それで誰でも我が子のためならもう何でもやるぞって
まあ奴隷です 欲 愛着 怒り
憎しみ 期待 希望 願望などは感情ですね
これいっぱいあるでしょう
だから我が子のためならもう死んでも惜しまないということになってしまうんです
その人間関係は全部こじれてしまいます
子供は聞きたくないんです
そんな言葉は あなたのことなら何でもやるぞという言葉は言ってるでしょう
私の派は逆です 何でもやると思ったら
ものすごい勘違いだと
あなたの 堂々と言うんです
私がやると部分があって
絶対やらないところもあります
あなたが自分でやらなくちゃいけないこともありますよと
覚えておけと あなたのことなら一度も聞いたことないんです
時々お菓子とか食べたいと言ったらね
そんなのは買うお金がない
だから諦めなさい はっきりそれで終わり
それで諦めるんです 諦めると同時に
自分も責任感のある社会人にちょっと変わってるんです
わがまま言うんじゃないんだよと
物事はいろいろ条件でできているんだよと
親がお菓子作ってあげることできれば
当然作ってくれる存在であると知っているんです
時々耳に入っちゃうんです
自分の母親も他のおばあさんたちと悩み事を言ったり
世間話したりする 子供たちにね
何か甘いものとか作って食べさせたいんだけどね
まあこれができなくてとかね
それちょこっとこれ自分に言ってることじゃなくて
ばあさん ばあさん上司が言ってることだからね
ちょっと耳に入っただけで
ああ なるほどとわかるんですよ
母親がやっぱりもう欲しいということは
あげたかないという気持ちはないんだけど
できないことはできないということに苦労しているんですよ
そこまで苦労しているならば
私も真面目に頑張らなくちゃいけないと
逆にこちらの心が変わるんです
はぁ 疲れました 感情から離れて子育てをすると
それが善行為になります
ですから感情から離れて
遺伝子からは離れません
おっぱいはあげます 出ますからね
しかし 感情から離れる
感情から離れて子育てすると
それが仏道なんです 善行為なんです
徳を積んでいることになるんです
だって大事な人間と命を育てているんだから
これすごいことでしょう
それで感情にどうやって勝てるのかと
1 理性です 理性入れちゃえば終わり
感情は負けます 客観的に自分の義務責任を理解する
お父さんもお母さんも客観的に
私たちはこれからどんな義務を果たさなくちゃいけないか
どんな責任があるのかとちゃんと理解しておけば
ああ 私のうちの子は可愛いんだから
王子様だからとかね そんなアホなことじゃなくて
赤ちゃんが生まれてきましたと
では この赤ちゃんをどのように育てるべきかと
いう義務を客観的に理解する
子が我が物でも所有物でもないこと
自分が子供を産んだんだからって
これ所有物になりませんよ
そう思っているでしょう
では 子供虐待したらどうなります？警察が来るでしょ
警察に言ってください
うちが産んだ子供だからね
私は勝手にしますよと
それでわかるでしょうに
自分が産んでも自分の子ではありません
なんでそれ理解しないんですかね
なんで感情の奴隷になって所有物やと思うんですかね
一人立ちする子が生命の一人
いわゆる人間の一員であること
子供が赤ちゃんの時からも何をやるのかというと
一人立ちしようとしているんです
成長というのはそんなもんなんです
だから思うことを思う
一人だけなんです だって
お腹の中にいると完全依存でしょ
この完全依存がなくなってしまいます
自分で呼吸しなくちゃいけない
自分でおっぱいを吸って栄養を取らなくちゃいかない
自分の力で 一部独立しちゃったんです
だからそれからも日々独立しようとしているんです
そこを掴む 捕まってねじって我が物にされて
とんでもない悪行為でしょ
またありえないことでしょ
そういうことを理解する
必ず親も子も離れる存在であること
これはもう離れる思いにずっと離れっぱなしなんです
親子関係っていうのは
立派な人として育てて社会に返すことが自分の仕事であること
我が子も輪廻というスケールで見られれば
見られれば子であること
我が子ではなくて 輪廻というスケールで見ると
ただ個人なんです 輪廻の生命が
生命の一人が自分の中に入っただけです
それを理解しておけば
したがって 当然自分と違う性格
個性を持って生まれることなどを理解する
ですから 自分が産んだ子供であっても個人であって
その子には個性がありまして
自分と違う性格があるんだと覚えておきましょう
全部忘れているでしょう
親に似ていないんだと
似ていないですね 似るわけがないんでしょうに
はい 感情に化す 個性を持って生まれる子が
人間の社会に生まれた国の生活パターンに適応できるようにオリエンオリエンテーションするんです
両親が何をやっているのかというと
こいつは個性を持って生まれたんだと
この輪廻でどんな性格を身につれてきたかわからないんだよと
しかし 生まれたら死ぬまで人間の社会で生きていなくちゃいけないんだよと
そこを心配してオリエンテーションするんです
日本で生まれたら箸の使い方を教えるんです
自分の国で生まれたら
行儀よく指でご飯を食べることを教えられるんです
西洋で生まれたら ナイフとフォークの使い方を教えてあげるんです
これがオリエンテーションです
自分自分と同じ色に染めてやることじゃないんです
この個性を育てる 個性を育てると言ったっても
そのままではダメですよ
過去生で何者でしたかとかわからないでしょうに
過去生で あの 何て言いますか
あの毒蛇でもであったならばね
あんた 毒蛇のように生き方しなさいと言ったってもね
これ困るでしょ  そんなことして
今は人間だからということでね
今は人間で 日本で生まれたんだから
日本の文化に合わせて生活しなくちゃいけないんだと
じゃあこれを教えてあげますよと言うことが親の仕事になるんです
それぐらいだったら親でなくても教えられるでしょ
だから人間には自分の子でなくても育てられます
躾っていうのはこれなんです
オリエンテーションです
だから躾するときでも
ものすごく気をつけてほしいポイントは
その子供は個性を持ってるんだと
個性を持って生まれたんだと
輪廻の一員ですよと  だからまず何者かとわからないんです
だから赤ちゃんの時から性格をチェックしてください
よく泣く子か よく笑う子か
泣いたらすぐ泣き止める子供か
泣いたらなかなか泣き止めることできない子か
いろいろ見えます そこで個性を見て
まあ適当にオリエンテーションしてあげなくちゃいけないんです
仏教の道徳に説得することができれば
完璧に育てたことになります
物事をわかってくると
殺生するなよとか 生命はあなたと同じ大事だよと
人を騙すなよと これはもう良くないことやといって
お釈迦様に説かれた道徳を教えてあげると
大体完璧に子供を育てたことになります
だから 仏教文化の国々では
子が親を殺すというケースはないんです
まあ完璧ゼロというわけではないんだけど
まあ大体はね ないとは言えます
2番目  1番目理性 理性に説明しました
2番目 慈しみ この感情に勝つ方法
奴隷にならない 奴隷の鎖を破って子供を育てる
その2番目は慈しみ 人間が皆知識人で理性的だと言えませんね
人間みんな理性的ではないんです
正しい子育ては理性だとすると
その人々が落ちこぼれになるんです
頭そんなに頭が良くなくて
まあ理性 知識がない人は落ちこぼれになりますよ
理性でしか子育てできませんよと言ったら大丈夫です
それでもしかし 感情がありますから
それを慈悲喜捨に変えるんです
全くもう頭の悪い 勉強したことも何もない
お母さんにしたっても
お父さんにしたっても
感情がありますね 我が子に対して
遺伝子が作ってくれますからね
遺伝子が感情を作ってくれますね
それで遺伝子が作った感情は別によりするんです
慈悲喜捨にしてしまうんです
そこで遺伝子の負け 慈悲喜捨に変えて子育てをするんです
微妙な調整で感情の入れ替えができます
それは親と子の関係に限ります
あの慈悲喜捨っていうのは
ほんのちょっとの調整でなります
これは親と親と子の間だけです
だから皆様も私たちも
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
気持ちになるために この微妙な調整しようと
そんなずるい話はないんです
我々は大人として慈悲の瞑想をしなくちゃいけないんです
瞑想して人格向上しなくちゃいけないんです
しかし 親と子の関係の場合は
こんな瞑想しなくたって
ちょこちょこと調整できます
で 最初は慈しみ メッターですね
次 アーリミ カルナです
できないこと わからないことを教えてあげるという気持ちです
子供が生まれてきたら
最初に慈しみで育てる
どんどん物事を教えてあげなくちゃいけなくなってくると
ああ この子にもこれもできない
あれもできないと見えてくるでしょう
そうすると ニコニコと
ああ こんな風にやりますよ
こういう風にやりますよ
これはこうだよとかね
で 弱いところ 間違っているところ
全部もうもう丹念に教えてあげる
教えてもわからない時は
また教えてあげる また教えてあげる
諦めないで この子供が成長するまで諦めないで
子供のことを心配するセクションが慈しみ
2番目ですね メッターですね
カルナですね それで子供が自分でいろいろできるようになると
子供も何でもかんでも自分でできるようになるんですよ
それで喜んであげるんです
18歳ぐらいになってくると
二十歳になってくると
もう親には全く依存しない
全部自分でやる その場合は喜んであげる
おかしいことというのは
子供が立ったら親がものすごく喜んじゃって
ビデオ撮ったり写真撮ったり
もうむちゃくちゃですけど
撮っただけですけどね
子供にとってはそのビデオを見せたっても
全然面白いことも何ともないんです
自分勝手に喜んでいるだけですよ
もう感情の奴隷なんです
しかし あ よくできたと子供はお母さんが喜んじゃうと子供は頑張るんです
それでも そこは記憶しておきなさいと頼んでないんです
それが後で忘れちゃうんですよ
子供は独立して自分の人生を生きようと思っちゃうと
もう怒るんですね なんで家に来ないんですか？とか
なんで一人で生活しようと思うんですか？とか
あれやこれやとか 親と子が仲良くいるのは
仲良くするのはもう普通じゃないんでしょうかとか
全くとんでもないへんてこりんなことを言うんです
普通っていうのは 親と子が別れることでしょうに
妊娠した瞬間からそれやってきたでしょうに
一人一人だけできたところから親子関係はシャウペッカーになるんです
それで子供が独り立ちできて
職業にも就いて 結婚もして
もう自分の世界を作ったんですね
その時になってくると
ウペッカー まあ冷静にいる
うちの子供だよっていう感じで
あんまり感情何もなく
あ そう まあ頑張ってる
まあよかったっていう感じで
それから自分が死ぬまで
その社の関係でいればいいんです
もう心配する必要もないんです
赤ちゃん の時からもうメッターで始めて
どんどんムディターになって
それからカルナになって
それからムディターをやって
それからシャーで全て終わりまで
そういうことで 親と親と子の関係が離れる関係ですが
慈悲喜捨入れちゃえば別にずっと関係あるんです
かえって慈悲喜捨っていうのは
我々一切の生命との仲良くすることだから
それで何の損もなく子育てはします
慈悲は他の生命の尊厳を認めることなので
全く問題がないんです
慈悲っていうのは 生命の尊厳を認めることなんですよ
親が子供の尊厳を認めてないんです
だから人権侵害しているんです
感情で遺伝子の命令で子供を育てていることは
人間が子供を育てていることが人権侵害なんです
結構やってるでしょ 慈しみだったら尊厳を認めることです
個性であること だから善行為なんです
はい 次のセクション 子が鬼になったっていう
可愛くていい子でしたのにね
これもよくあることで
まあ大人になるとね 暴力を振るったり
親に依存したりね 一人立ちできなかったり
仕事をしなかったり 親を恨んだりなどのケースがあります
まあ当然こそ先生は大失敗っていうことですけどね
それは感情の問題ですね
親が感情で育てるから必ずと言えるほど子が問題を起こします
そこで親が感情ばっかしだから
どうしても子供は多かれ少なかれ何か問題を起こすんです
なぜかというと 感情は理性の反対なんです
天と地の差があるんです
感情があると必ずバカなことをするんです
だから どんな家族でも
多かれ少なかれ子供はなんとかトラブルを作るんです
その原因は親の感情にあるんです
暴力などの問題は人間関係の問題です
この暴力振るっていうことは
当然子供がもう大きいでしょ
大人でしょ 時々小学生も暴力振ったりすることありますけど
その瞬間で人間関係を教えてあげなくちゃいけないんです
大人になった子は親に暴力振るならば
そのそいつはもう人間関係を知らないんです
暴力で何も通じないでしょ
世の中で暴力って犯罪でしょうに
親は我慢するんです とんでもない親なんです
これが犯罪ですよ だから小学生の子でも暴力振ったらもう痛くはないかもしれませんだけど
何か悪い言葉言ったりとかね
もうなんかやったと その時でもものすごい厳しく犯罪扱いされなくちゃいけないんですね
これは犯罪だよと そんな言葉を使うならば
あなたのことを何もやってあげませんよと
じゃあ勝手にやってくださいと
すぐその時狂暴になって言わなくちゃいけないんです
仲良くすることでしょうと
あんた何か欲しいのであればくださいと言いなさいよと
くださいと言わなかったら
お母さん聞きませんよと
あるいはお願いしますと言いなさいよ
ここは家でお母さんから学ばなきゃ
あんたはもう刑務所で終わりますよ
人生は そのまま言えばいいんですよ
あの子供っていうのは
小さい時 ものすごい論理的なんです
親には 大人には敵わないぐらい論理なんです
だから論理で言えばいいんです
この時々 親がね この子は何回言ってもこれこれやってくれないんだ
あれやこれ私に言われたらいいですよと
で 私に任せてくださいと
親には 1年もかかるんだけど
私にはだいたい 10分で十分です
何の秘密もないんです
私はじりじりと理論で喋るんです
理論には感情がないんです
あんたやりたければやってくださいと
理論とおかしいことやっちゃうとバカに決まってるでしょうと
それは言わないんです
理論を言うと 理論は壊しちゃうとものすごく恥ずかしくてバカだとクールじゃないと本人わかってるんだから
うまくいきます で まあ私は具体的になれば結構ありますけど
まあ最近 今思い出して 1つケースいますけど
まあ親がこの子はいくら言っても歯を磨かないんだよと
そしたら私は ああそうですか
どうせこいつは猿だからと何とか言ったんです
そしたらこうはニコニコとね
でも私の歯はすごい元気ですよと
虫歯 1本もないんだよと
と言うんです そこで私は理論崩れてるんだとわかったんです
私は親にも何もはい わかりましたと
それで終わって それから私はもう二人だけでね
あのね この虫歯になっても構わないよと
歯が簡単に治せますよと
いたって簡単に 歯がなくなったっても
入れ歯つけられますからね
今は何の問題もないんだと
しかし 口の中ではね 小さな子供だからね
1億かける 1億ぐらい細菌があるんだよ
ものすごいいますよと
これが口が汚れていると
もう成長して成長して口いっぱい細菌いっぱいわよと
それであなたは じゃあ水飲みましょうと水 1杯飲んでも
汚れた汚染された水を飲んでいるんだよと
細菌で普段は触りたくもないものやと
あんたこのなんかリンゴ食べようと
あなたにはリンゴを食べられませんよと
あなたは腐って汚染されたものを食べてるんだよと
それを食べて それは血液に入って
腎臓に入って 肝臓に入って
いろんなところに細菌が入ってる
あなたはもうクタクタ早くも病気になって死んでしまいますよと
そのデータは嘘ではなくて
いろんな科学ジャーナルを読んで得た知識なんです
その時 子供にわかるように心臓発作も起こしますよ
あの いろんなこの高血圧やらコレステロールの問題やら
もう腎臓がいかれることやら
結構歯が原因なんです
歯磨きというのはそういうことやと
虫歯じゃないんだよと
それだけ 話を話には まあまあ 5分
6分ぐらいかかったと思いますよ
さっさと立ち上がって歯ブラシを持って行って歯を磨いたんです
それからえらいニコニコと歯を磨くんです
だから私 なんで親が言うこと聞かなかったというと
親って感情でしょうね
虫歯にならないように歯を磨けというのは完璧な事実じゃないんです
歯を磨いても虫歯になるやつらはなるんです
結局は 私はしっかりした理論を言ったんです
それだけ 磨きなさいとはないんです
データはこれこれで はい
さようならと 結構小さな子供たちはデータだけ与えれば自分で判断するんです
そういうことで この暴力の場合は
これは人間関係の問題ですから
すぐそこを教えてあげないと
子供が大人になったら親子関係が終えた
人間関係が起きたです
自分の子供が大人になったら
大体 16  17になったらもう親子関係は終えましたと
これから人間関係だよと
いうふうに人間関係にしなくちゃいけないんです
人間関係は自比喜捨の捨なんです
お互い責任を持って責任を渡して
契約交わして生活しましょうと
だから大人になってからは
社会の一人の人間として
たとえ家族の中でもそう見なくちゃいけないんです
18歳の頃 朝を起こさないと起きないならば大きな問題です
それはあなたの責任でしょうにと
子供じゃないんだから
子供の時は起こしてあげましたよと
もう時計も読めないし
もう寝ちゃったら寝るし
大人になったら自分で起きなさいと
うん この人間関係を教えてあげると
まあ私はいろいろ実験してあるんですよ
まあ五歳六歳の子供でもね
私のところに一緒に夜寝ようかなと来たら
私はそこで人間関係を作るんですね
知ってます 子供は朝早く起きません
あれやこれやとかね それは大人として面倒見ますけど
でも一応 じゃあ今日で私はこの時間に起きますからね
その時間で君も起きません
起きなきゃダメですよ
って言ってあげるんです
私は起こしませんからと
ちゃんと起きます 時々先に起きちゃって私を起こすんです
私はもうあと 1時間ありますからね
もうちょっと寝てもいいよと
だからこの人間関係を築けば
結構子供はすごい元気で
なんかえらい責任を持って
子供とそれはすごく楽しいんですよ
自分を認めること だからこの暴力などというのは人間関係の問題ですね
二つの関係が混じってはならないんです
この今 関係 2つ教えたでしょ
親子関係と人間関係 親にはその親子関係はある時期で終わります
俺は動物と同じ そこで親子関係切っちゃって
それから人間関係を作るんです
人間関係 死ぬまで続きます
だから慈悲喜捨なんです
親子関係はカルナとムディタとカルナ
メッターとカルナとムディタで 3つで慈悲喜で
人間関係は捨でいくべきものです
はい どうにもならないということで
輪廻の業によって性格が合わないことも
敵同士になることも稀にあり得るんです
もう輪廻の中にいる無数の限りない生命の中で
一人が入り込んでくるんだから
生まれるチャンスがあったら
誰が生まれるかわからないんです
女性のお腹の中で子供が生まれる状況が揃ったら
どんな生命が入ってくるかよくわからないんです
だから小さい時から慈悲の瞑想した方がいいんです
体から慈悲の波動を出していると
近寄らないんですよ 悪い波動が
まあかなりもうね 慈悲の気持ちを持ってる天界の人々とかね
自分の寿命が終わったら
似ている波動に宿ってくるんです
だから慈悲の瞑想する人には
もう過去世で天界でいた人とか入ってくるんです
これで結構幸せなんですよ
何の問題もなく 体の問題もないし
性格の問題もないし 明るいし
で そうではないんだから
普通の人々はね ですから
誰が入ってくるかわからない
時々 まれにまるっきり性格が合わない敵同士みたいな性格の生命も入ってくるんです
時々 虐待 子を殺す 殺害するなどの原因にもなります
その時は親がどうにもわからないんだけど
子供を虐待してしまうんです
子供も泣くは泣くは 親がイラッとする所まで
普通子供が泣くとも なんかかわいらしくて
もうもうたまらないんですよ
なんとかしなくちゃっていう風になっちゃうんです
時々 まあもうわー嫌だ
この親となっちゃうんです
それで赤ちゃんの時からもう泣き声がお母さんにイライラで殴っちゃうってケースもありますね
その時はもう揺するんだけど
それもいい加減で 赤ちゃん
お母さんもストレスかかってるんだから苛立ってるんだから
抱っこしたっても子供は泣き止まないんです
もうすごく相手人がはいはい
なんとか何のこともないんだよとか
その優しさがないんです
ただ抱っこしてこうやったり揺すったりするだけで
さらに泣いちゃうんです
それでこの子は抱っこしたっても泣いてるんだと
おっぱいあげたっても泣いてるんだと
これで虐待してしまっちゃうこともありますね
だからそこを気をつけた方がいいんです
お母さんが精神的な病気でないならば
もしかするともう性格が合わないということもあります
本来の生命には子供を殺すっていうことできない
遺伝子にはそんなプログラムはないんです
遺伝子が我が子利己だからね
自分が生き続けたいだけだから
子供を殺したら困ります
だったらなんで親が子を殺すんですかね
それで過去の業でなければ
それはありえないんです
過去では怖い敵同士の性格
解決方法は子供を欲しがる誰かにあげることです
これはもうどうにもならん
その場合は誰かにあげるしかないんです
なぜならば 人間なら誰にでも育てられます
全然問題ないんです 産んだ母でなければ
産んだ父親でなければというのは
こんなのは冗談 せっかく生まれてきた人間なので
幸せにさせないといけないんです
だから 自分には全く子育ての気持ちが出てこないわ
もう見たくもないわと言ったっても
自分が産んだ子供だから
どこかで幸せで結果にいい人間になってほしいという気持ちで誰かにあげればいいんです
日本でそんなことできるかできないかってのは
私の問題じゃありません
はい これでまあ疲れましたので
ちょっと休憩いたします
はい 今 あの親のセクション
ものすごい論理的に説明しました
科学的にも論理的にも
現代思考にも合わせて全部説明しました
それから子供の義務というところにあります
親の優しさは無料とは勘違いと
で みんなそう思っているんです
フリーオブチャージだと
親が子供のことを心配するのは調子に乗りすぎです
で なぜかというと この親が本当に何でもやってあげる
何も期待しないんです
今日すき焼き作ってあげたんだからね
これまあもう千九百円ちょうだいとかね
はないんです 子供はもうバクバク食べれば取れて楽しいんです
自分の分も半分も食べちゃっても全然へっちゃらなんです
それで子がそんなのはもうフリーオブチャージで決まっているんだよと
親が私のことを心配するのは
と それが勘違いなんです
そこで理屈が崩れてます
親たるものは子供のためには何でもします
それでお金ちょうだいとは言わないんです
だからって子供に そんなのは親が何でもやるべきやと思う権利がないんです
そこを覚えておいてください
親のサービスはフリーオブチャージですが
子供はそう思ってはならないと
なぜならば 私たち一人一人が個人です
輪廻転生する生命なので
子は個人です 自分を何の見返りを期待しないで
子供のことを優先にして
苦労に苦労をかけて 精神的に悩みながら親が自分を育てたんです
それを理解しないと 自分が輪廻の生命なんです
個人です なのにこの親がまあ私を優先にしちゃって
自分のことはもう後回しにして
苦労に苦労をかけてよく育てたんだと
変わらない見方で常に心配するんです
親っていうのは子供の変わらない見方なんです
それから子供のことを常に心配するんです
親の愛情は無限ですが
無料にはならないんです
それを覚えておきましょう
親の愛情は無限ですが
無料にはなりませんと
無料とは親の感情で 子供には関係がありません
これは人間関係の中でも同じことでしょうね
誰かがまあいいよいいよって言って
いろんなことを我々にやってくれると
私たちはどこかでその人のことをやっぱり大事にしたり
まあなんとかったら 私もなんとか恩返ししなくちゃいけないということが生まれてるでしょうに
あんた気にすることがね
まあこれこれ持っていってくださいとかね
おいしいご飯食べさせますから
もう大丈夫ですよと それから忘れてくださいと言っても
おいしいご飯を食べた人が
やっぱりあの人はすごくいい人で
私がお腹が空いてるとか
結構ごちそうさせてくれましたとかね
そこを覚えておくでしょうに
だからやってあげる側は無料でやっても
やってもらう側にはそれなりの恩が生まれているんです
輪廻と業があるから 確実に親に返しきれない借りがあるんです
輪廻と業があるからという
ちょっと難しいんですね
輪廻で考えれば 自分が輪廻してるんですね
勝手に そこで生まれる
生まれるところで そちらにいる親がものすごい育ててくれるんですよ
だから結構これ便利にできちゃってね
どこかで生まれたら これ親っていう 2人が待ち構えているんだから育ててあげるぞとか
だからそこは恩返ししないと
それから 業っていうのは自分の業でしょ
自分が幸福になるか 不幸になるか
障害者になるか もう何になるかは自分の業の結果なんです
それに構わず親が育てるんです
ですから借りがあるんです
子供の性格が悪くても親が育てるんです
だから自分が 私は隔世で悪い性格で生まれてね
それでもよくやってくれましたと
親も輪廻の中では他人ですからね
ですから ものすごいそこを恩返ししなくちゃいけなくなるんです
で また元に戻りますけど
遺伝子と感情のこと 親孝行は遺伝子に記録されてないです
これよく覚えてください
子に対する愛情は我々の遺伝子に入っています
子を愛しなさいと だから子を愛することは善行にならないんです
子育ては善行にならない
あれは遺伝子のからくりです
善行にしたければ 理性が使う理性を使うか
慈悲喜捨でやるかなんです
それで子供の遺伝子の中に親を尊敬しなさいと入ってないんです
子供の感情は自分の幸福を一方的に考える自我中心的なものです
子供は一方的に自分のことしか気にしない
ちっちゃな子はわかるでしょうに
いつでも自分のことばっかり心配するんです
親のこと全然気にしない
それで親の遺伝子で親がまあそれが可愛いと言うんですけど
でもそちらに問題が起こるんです
そちらで親のことも気にしなさいと教えてあげなくちゃいけないんです
親も疲れますよと ですから
子供っていうのはものすごい自己主義者なんです
もう利己主義者なんです
これは遺伝子に入ってないんです
親孝行しなさいと 自分が弱い時は親に依存するんですして
育ててもらうんです どんどんもう自分で生活できるようになっちゃうと
さようならという あなたのこと知りませんよということになるんです
動物の世界では これは明らかなんですね
人間の世界ではこんな完璧に独立できるんだから
それでもなんとかなんとか感情的なコネを持ってます
遺伝子と感情の奴隷になることは悪
これ漢字になってない
悪行為です 悪 悪い行為です
善行為にはなりません
遺伝子のいい奴隷になることは悪行為です
善行為ではないんです
だから子供が弱い時 親に頼ってるんだけど
独立した途端もう自分の世界に飛び飛んでいくんです
これは遺伝子にあるもの
遺伝子の言うままなんです
ですから それがそんなに善行為にはなりません
倫理道徳は感情に勝つことです
倫理と道徳っていうのは
この感情に 遺伝子のプログラムに勝つことなんです
そこで親孝行っていうのは出てくるんです
だから親孝行は遺伝子に記録してないんだからこそ
素晴らしい善行為なんです
一番簡単に良い人間になります
人に親切にすることはできますよ
他人に それで社会の関係だからね
しかし 親に親切にすること
親を心配すること 親の幸福を願うことは
その気にならないんです
面白いことに だから人なら先に親のことを心配することにする
親を助けようとする それが遺伝子の記録にないことだから
普通の善行為よりはとても素晴らしい善行為なんです
人間として大成功する方法はそれなんです
人間としてこの社会で成功したければ
まず親孝行することです
それしないんだったらもう失格です
恩知らずだから 社会は心配するはずもないんです
一生の味方の面倒も見てないんだから
味方を裏切るんだから
だから 人生大成功に収めたければ
親孝行で始めなくちゃあかんです
親が子にとって梵天です
神様です 梵天とはバラモン教が説く創造神です
子供を全面的に心配する親が梵天そのものなんです
お釈迦様はすごい客観的な理論で
生命を育て 生んで育てるのは梵天だったら
これは親のことだろうといきなり言うんです
それでポイント終わり
親孝行するべき 話終わり
親孝行しなかったらあんた人間でもないんだよっていうことで
そこも命まで与えて 一人前にして社会人にしてあげて
それは恩は知りませんよと
親が厳しかったよと 親に殴られたこともあるよと
あれやこれやとか もうそれ失格
私は親に悪口言う人はもう全然相手にしないんです
ある精神的にひどい病気になっている人がいて
ずっと電話かけていろんなアドバイスしたりして
ある日 その人はものすごい凶暴になったりしますけど
ずっと薬漬けで なんかもういろいろ薬もやめたい
あれやこれやと言いながらね
そこでもう親のことはもう嫌で嫌でたまらんと
だから父親にいろいろ迷惑をかけたり
タイヤをパンクしたり
で 何が？だって今仕事を退職して家にいるんだからうるさいと
で あなたはね ずっと家にいるでしょ
外へ行くこともなくて
それは私は病気だからしょうがないでしょうと
こういう人らの理論なんですかね
自分が病気だから親に食べさせてもらって
もうもう 20 何歳かもわからないんだけど
仕事はで退職して家にいる
父親がいるのは嫌なんですよ
出ていけという態度なんです
そこで なんかだんだんだんだんもう親に対してあれこれ言ったら
私はいきなりちょっと待ってくださいと
あなた親を恨むならば
親の悪口を言うならば
親を殺害しようと思うならば
もうこちらに電話かけてこないで
これっきりで話が終わるよと
私もあなたに親切にしないんだ
あんた病気とかなんとかとか
そんな話私は乗りませんよと
病気に隠れて親を殴ったりする権利もあなたはないんだよと
それは無条件で あなた親のことはなんとかして
もう親孝行しなくちゃあかんやと
何もできんだったら 最低私の面倒を見てくれるんだからという
それぐらい覚えておきなさいと
その話だったら あなたの相談相手には絶対なりませんと
それで終わり さようならで電話かけちゃったんです
精神的な病気で私は親切になれない
その時はそれぐらい親孝行しなきゃもう終わりなんですね
人生は という人は 自分が野蛮人で親を尊敬できないという人はね
自分は野蛮人で文化人でではないと宣言しているだけです
私は親 私の親は尊敬できませんと言ったらね
親が悪いんじゃないんです
仏教ではまあ前も説明したでしょうね
親っていうのは悪行為をする親もいるし
犯罪をする親もいるし
しかしそれは親と子の関係には関係ないでしょう
世の中の独裁者もいるでしょ
ひっちゃらで人を殺す
例えばリビアのガダフィもすごい独裁者で
しかし国の全資産 自分と子どもたちだけで
分けて分かち合ってあって
だから子どもから見れば
この親は独裁者で殺さなくちゃとか
それはあり得ないんです
ガダフィを追い出せならば
これは国民もやるしかないんです
で 親が人間なので 試行錯誤で子育てに苦労しているんです
苦労したのです 親って人間ですから
完璧じゃないでしょうに
親はまあ試行錯誤でやってますよ
少々間違いの少々の間違いのみを覚えて
無量の愛情を忘れるのは恐ろしい性格です
親が失敗したらゲラゲラと笑っちゃえばいいでしょうに
あるいはそこらへんかばせてあげればいいでしょうに
自分の間違い いつでも親がかばせてくれるでしょうに
これだけ覚えるんだったら
親の無量の愛情を忘れるならば
親が殴ったことがあるとある人が言ったんですよ
私に あんたは生まれてから今まで殴ったこと
殴ってきたんですかと
これはどう計算しても何回だけでしょうにと
それもあなたがそれなりのもうやんちゃで反抗気で危険なことをやった時だけでしょうにと
なんでそれだけ覚えているんですかと
なんであんた親をあなたを抱っこしてたことを忘れてるんですかと
父親が子供を抱っこしている時間と子供を殴っている時間
比較したらどうですかね
不正があったら 子供に寝るまで絵本を同じおつまらない絵本をね
同じ本を毎日毎日読んであげているんだから
なんでそれを忘れるんですかね
ですから もう親に親を尊敬できないと言ったら
もう自分が宣言していますね
私は野蛮人であると これ大災になります
確実に不幸になります
たとえ虐待を受けたことがあっても
なんとか育てたので文句を言う権利はありません
時々しつけで殴られることじゃなくて
虐待を受けることもあります
それはすごい悲しい出来事ですけど
で 親にいろいろ問題があったりしてね
時々虐待してもなんとか育てる場合ありますよ
それだったらそこを覚えなくちゃいけないんですね
私の性格が悪くて 親と相性が悪くて虐待を受けましたと
やっぱりそれでもいろいろまあ育ててくれましたと
借金などを独り立ちしている子供の人生を食らわせたり
借金などで時々借金などをして親が借金するんでしょ
勝手に で まあ子供はもう仕事してますから
あいつは払うだろうと
お嫁をいじめたりする親もたびたびいます
たびたび子供の人生を台無しにする人々はいます
それは親に問題があります
お嫁さんをいじるんだいじめるんだったら
やっぱりお母さんに問題あるんです
いじめる権利はないんです
それはもう息子のお嫁さんです
病気です それは そうなってくると
息子に責任がありますから
お嫁さんを守る 出て行くしかないんです
二人を会わせないようにするしかないんです
そうなってくると お嫁さんも意地があるんだから
孫を見せてくれないということになるんです
それは女同士の戦いでしょうに
それにおばあさんがもんぎったってもね
悪いお嫁で孫を連れてこないんだと
お嫁が嫌ですけど 孫と遊びたいと
調子に乗るんじゃないよ
孫とむちゃこちゃ遊びたければ
お嫁さんのことを我が娘のように愛しなくちゃいかんです
娘のように愛してあげると
もう孫を放り出していくんです
もうどうぞ勝手にしてくださいと
でないと親にも感情があるんだから
もう預かりたくはなくなるんです
子供 こと人間関係を築いてないんですね
だから子供ではないんで
もう人間関係です 結婚した時点で親子関係はもう終わったんです
それから人間関係です
そこは気づいてないんです
それで父親が勝手に借金したりして
それで子供が 苦労して借金払わなくちゃいかんとかね
それ払ったところでまたやっちゃうとかね
これってもうとんでもないことです
その時 子が身を守るのは構わない
その時 自分の身を守るためにいろいろ親からそっと離れたりとか
もう関係ないことにするとか
なんとかしなくちゃいけないんです
そういう特例だけですよ
あの それでも親が衰えていくと面倒を見るべきなんです
鬼のように親であっても
衰えていくと何もないかったような感じで面倒を見るべきなんです
何もできなくなったら借金もできませんし
仕事もいじり見ることもできませんし
もう寝たきりになったりするとね
その時は全部面倒を見る
完全な恩返し 親孝行しても恩返しにはならないとは仏教の考えで
これを前に説明しました
親に徳を済ます 善行為をさせる
修行するチャンスを与える
死後不幸にならないようにすることで恩返し完了です
親が道徳を守る 瞑想もする
仏教も学ぶ人間に何とか工夫してその興味を作ってあげれば
もう完了です 人間の日常の生き方を道徳に富んだ生き方に変えることは
理性的な仏教的な生き方です
ですから 子育てっていうのは誰でもやっていること
それが理性で入れ替えると道徳的になります
仕事は誰でもやっている
それが慈しみでやると善行為になります
友達作ることは誰でもやっています
しかし 慈しみでそこをやると善行為になります
ですから 仏教というのは我々の何の変哲もない普段の生き方
日常の生活そのものを善行為に入れ替える方法なんです
はい これで話は終わりです
はい どうもありがとうございます
先生ありがとうございます
まだ若干時間ございますので
質問などございます方
挙手していただきましたらマイクを回しますので
ぜひ質問させてください
もうもう大丈夫です 完璧です
はい  初めの頃におっしゃったお釈迦様が自分の死をみんなお釈迦様が自分の足を自分で洗われたというのは何か意味があることなんですか？ うーん
まあ誰もお釈迦様の体触らないでしょう
阿難尊者以外は あまりにも尊い方だからね
大体誰も触らないんです
まあお釈迦様はまあたまたまね
自分の息子をね まあ手で繋いで手を繋いで連れて行ったとかね
まあそれはありますけどね
まあそれ以外はないと思います
で まあブッダですからね
まあ自分の面倒見なさいと言っちゃうと
もうものすごいみんな揃ってむちゃくちゃ喧嘩しながらやろうとしてるしね
だからそこで我々にとってはいかに偉大なるお釈迦様も
自分のことは自分でやりましたということなんです
いかに謙虚で だから私たちにはまあね
出しゃばるなよとかね
日本の新興宗教の開祖様たちみたいでね
あんな調子になるなよというアドバイスでしょう
仏陀さんも謙虚で 自分の托鉢は自分でして
年取ってから阿難尊者にちょっと助けてくれということになっただけで
だから人間っていうのはそういう風に謙虚に生きていなくちゃいけないんですよ
我々はすごい勝手に あんたこれやりなさい
これやりなさい これ持ってこい
あれ持ってこいとか お茶
お茶 これとかね 奥さんに対しても態度悪いでしょうに
おい お茶とか言うでしょうに
それで夫婦関係崩れるでしょうね
なんだ そんな態度 お釈迦様さえも取らなかった態度でしょうに
だからなんで優しく言わないんですかね
ちょっとお茶一杯飲みたいなとかね
喉が渇いたなとかね 誰かがお茶一杯入れてくれればありがたいなとかね
そう言われるとお坊さんがすっごく喜んじゃいますよ
で 私にはこの命令するっていうことが理解できないんですね
なんで人に命令するんでしょうかと
私はもう子供たちにも自分の弟子たちにも命令はしません
アイデアを提供する こういうことですけど
で 例えば出家したら お寺の掃除することも修行の一環だよと
それやらないで朝寝坊しちゃったら
もう出家としてはふさわしくないんだよというだけで
それでもこいつはやらないんだけど
私の弟子たちは決まって頭が悪いんだからしょうがないしね
まあ似ているみたいです
で やってほしければ簡単ですよ
もう言うことを出家としてやること何もやらんだけど
私が命令すると喜んでやっちゃうんです
時々たまたまもういろんなことで忙しくてもう私の一人なんかできない時はこちょいでとかね
これやってくれと言ったら喜んでやるんです
でも私はそれがそんなに好きじゃないんです
命令することだから そういうわけでお釈迦様がまあ自分の足を自分で洗ったということは
まあそういう意味が入っていると思います
はい じゃあ  手を上げておいていただけますか
妹と仲が悪いんですが
妹と仲が悪いんです 表ではなんか嫌いな態度をして
何かの時にやたらと心配してきても気持ちが悪いです
あのね 女性っていうのは男よりも早く大人になるんです
女で生まれたら その時からもうこの遺伝的にすごい責任感があるんです
だからあなたをお兄ちゃんと思えないんです
もうかわいそうでどうにもならん生命やと思ってしまうんです
だからそこら辺は男で生まれたんだからね
もう我慢するしかないんです
向こうはいつでも態度はでかいんです
だからそこは逆にうまく使っちゃえばね
いろいろことを頼んでみたりとかね
もう助けてもらったりとかね
するともう結構やってくれますよ
褒めてあげて 特に褒めてあげてください
なんかああ いいですね
あんたはね 私は下手ですけどとかね
そういうふうに女性は強いんですよ
存在の中で それはもうどうすることもできない
私でももう五 六歳の女の子たちはえらい態度で
あなたはね こうこうしなさいって言ってくれるんだから
こちらはもうむちゃくちゃじじいですけど
まだ何の親戚関係もないんだけど
もうしつけしようとするんです
で 私はそれでニコッと
あ そうですかね よくわかりました
教えてくれてありがとうと言うんです
それはもう子供にとってはどうしようもないんです
子供女の子だから だからあなたは男として
男っていうのは守ってあげなくちゃいけないというね
そういう態度をとっていない可能性もあります
いろいろ じゃあもう私がやってあげます
この男 あれやこれやとかね
微妙になんか味方になって守ってあげるような雰囲気はしていないとも思いますし
まあそれはできないんだったら構わないんだけど
まあ逆にやっぱり褒めてあげたり
いろいろ助けてもらったりとかね
そういうやり方でやってみてください
うん まあ大体まあ兄弟っていうのは競争しますからね
いいですか  ん？ もう一個いいですか？ はい
親父が精神科医なんで
たまに強烈な負の波動を家に持ち込んで大変な目にあうんですけど
どうすればいいですか？たまにそれが原因で親父が痛風になって大変な目になったんですよ
その時はね ストレスなくなるようにしてあげるのはね
まああなたのお母さんとかね
あなた方の仕事ですけどね
で まあなんとかね 今日はお父さんがね
ストレスいっぱいたまっちゃって暗いなとかなんとか言うか
まあちょっともうちょっと楽しみましょうよと
ゲームでもやりましょうよとかね
言って助けてあげることも仕事でしょ
で 仕事中はね 大変ですからね
仕事っていうのはね まあだから子供はかわいくてたまらんというふうにね
まああなた方も可愛いと思われるように態度するならば
もう家に来ただけでホッとするんです
全部忘れちゃって 子供たちとふざけて遊ぶことにするんです
で 特に父親っていうのは
ものすごい子供たちとふざけて遊びたいんです
だからまあ その機会があればこの問題は消えると思います
適当に頑張ってみてください
はい はい あの こちら側
えっとですね 先ほどですね
親を絶対に敬わなければ
私は耳が遠くなっちゃって
ちょっと  いけないとおっしゃっていたんですけども
親が本当捨ててしまって
他のタイプに預けてしまったと
それでも厄介なことに
親がどんな人か知っていると
そういう場合はどのようにすればよろしいでしょうか
うーん  あと 親が途中まで育てて
途中でどっかに行ってしまったと
そういう場合はどうしたらよろしいでしょうか
別にどうする必要ないでしょ
これってアメリカなんかはしょっちゅうあることでしょ
敬わなければいけない
ん？ 産んだだけで どっかの誰かに預けてしまった場合でも
それはそれとして敬うと
ちょっとわからないけど
ただ産んだだけで育てる行為をしていない場合でも
あるいは途中まで育てて
何かの事情で他の人にあげちゃったりした場合でも
親として敬う対象になるかと
その場合はこの うーん
親っていうことは消えませんね
だから例えば殺したら仏教の五逆罪になります
産んで捨てたとしましょう
産んで捨てても 捨てたら子供は当然知らないでしょ
誰が親かと  そうではなくて
誰かから聞かされて 捨てた人の親が誰なのかを知っているんです
だから育ての親とは別に
誰々さんが実は自分の親だということを知っているんですね
その場合はどうでしょう
その場合は別にその程度でいいんじゃないんですかね
いや だから捨てる 捨てて親が自分の生活しているでしょ
そこで年取ったり病気になったりすると
そちらで面倒を見てあげてあげてるでしょうに
だから自分が自分を育ててくる人々と人間関係正しく築いて
そこで恩返しをする で
自分を捨てた親が自分が知ってるんだけど
その世界でまあ自分の世界を築いているならば
これは放っとしてあげるんです
しかし 捨てて偉そうに出て行っちゃったんだけど
今寝たきりになって誰も面倒を見ていない惨めな姿になっているんだとわかったところで
サッと行って面倒を見るべきなんです
それは自分の幸福になります
育ててくれてもないし
捨てられたし それでも産んだ親だから
もう自分で何もできなくなったところで全部やってあげるんだよと
ことが仏教的には道徳なんです
だから感情の答えではなくて
理性の答えなんですね
正しいのは 感情的に言えば放っておけなんでしょ
私捨てたんだから面倒見る義務がないんだぞというのは感情的な答えなんですね
だからそこで理性的な答えを探すんですね
理性的な答えは 自分を捨てた親がまあ元気で生きている
それだったら放っておく
あるいは調べたら元気で生きてるどころじゃなくて
ひどい目に遭っているんだとわかったら
助けてあげるということになります
親の方が関わろうと思ってなければ
特にこちらから行くことはないということなんでしょうか
ん？ 親の方がこちらに関わろうと思っていないならば
別に何もしなくても良いということ
なるほど  親の方が自分に関わろうとしていない場合
そういう場合は別に自分からわざわざ行かなくて
それはそうでしょ  でもそしたらその恩は返せないということになるのではないですか
そうなりますね だからそれは業の輪廻の問題で
あの 何かどこかに問題あるんですね
結局は だから哺乳類だから産んだ子供を愛情を持って育てるのは遺伝子でしょ
遺伝子のこともおかしくなっちゃってるんだから
どこかに問題があるんです
あるいは自分と親の輪廻の関係があまり良くない場合もあります
だから親孝行できないケースっていうのはいくらでもありますよ
例えば 自分が親孝行できる年になってくると
親が亡くなっているとかね
例えば親がもう自分がもう 15歳でお母さんが癌で亡くなったとかね
そんなことっていうのはもういくらでもありますよ
その場合も ５つの項目あったんですね
親の義務はシガーラ経典から引用したところで
亡くなった親に供養するという
それでも自分たちが亡くなった場合は供養するんですね
なんかいいことをして両親にも回向しますと
そういうケースは出てきます
親子できなくて 恩返しできなくても
それはそれで仕方がいないという感じなんでしょうか
そうそう だから現実的に
まあそういう風に不可能になった場合は
親は自分を捨てて 自分に構わないで生活するとかね
こちらに来るなよとも関係ないんだというならば
何もしてあげることはできない
そういう現実的に不可能な時はもうできませんだからね
それは話題にならないんです
追っかけて行って孝行するっていうことはね
それほどはならないと思います
ありがとうございました
はい 最後前の方  今の今出てる親の義務の中にですね
適した相手と結婚させるっていうのがあるんですけども
今の時代というか 私なんかもそうなんですけれども
結婚しない人というのが非常に増えていると思うんですね
そうしますと 子供が結婚しない場合というのは
その親はやっぱりその義務を果たせていないということになってしまうのか
あるいはその今の現代的な
あの なんていうんでしょうか
考え方というのができるでしょうか
あともう一つは その子供の側からすると
先ほどのお話でも 結婚して初めてきちんと親から独立するっていうようなお話だったと思うんですけれども
その結婚しないで ちゃんと独立するっていうことはできるのか
その結婚しない場合に関して
その親の側と子供の側と
どういうふうに考えればいいかとか
何か気をつけることが
そこは複雑だと思いますね
まずは仏教的には簡単ですから
人が結婚するかしないかっていうのは
その人の自由なんです
まず 例えば私がね 小さい時からじゃあ出家すると決めちゃったんだからね
それは私の自由で で 生まれかけた人は必ずしも結婚しなくちゃいけないということはないんです
だから 結婚するかしないかっていうことは
そんな程度のことで 本人がしたければしてもよろしい
したくなければそれでもよろしいし
で 問題が出てくるのは
なんで結婚しないのかっていうところなんですね
そこで考えなくちゃいけないんですよ
例えば 自分の親の関係があまりにも良くなくて
それを見たら もう例えば父親がすごいお母さんをいじめたり
バイオレンスをしたりして
それ見てね こんな生活は嫌やと
言ったりすると まあそこはまあ
それで結婚する気にならないとかね
それは出てくる 自分も虐待を受けたら
そういうふうな心理的な原因も出てきますね
それはそれなりに解決しなくちゃいけない
それから 自分が一人で生きてみるぞとかね
一人で遊んで楽しく生きていますよと
結婚しちゃったらこれできなくなるんだよって言ったら
ちょっとわがまま過ぎなんですね
この一人で楽にいようと思って独立している人々は
後でかなり大変なことになります
だって献身的なことを何もやってないんだから
自己出張だけでしたからね
だから自分の快楽のために
自分の楽しみのために結婚しないということは
それはあんまり良くないと思います
結婚することというのは楽しいことじゃないんです
本当は もう大変なことなんです
突然すごい責任が迫ってくるんです
で 一人でいるよりは結婚したら
もう社会に対する責任というのはものすごくなるんです
自分の親戚もガクンと増えてしまうしね
だからそれでも頑張ってみますよというところで
わがままはどんどん減っていくんですね
例えば 自分の親だけではなくて
もう旦那の親の面倒を見なくちゃいけなくなってくると ４
人の面倒を見る羽目になっちゃいますから
仕事量増えるんですよ
仕事が増えれば増えるほど
自分のわがまま時間がなくなっていくんですね
だからその点ではいいところなんですね
だから結婚すると言ったって
それは楽なことじゃないんですね
まあ臆病で もう弱くて逃げるって人々もいます
まあ精神的に自分にとっては責任持てないというならば
結婚するのは迷惑ですね
相手に対しては 例えば精神的な問題ある人々もさっさと結婚してしまう場合もあります
それはちょっと無責任な態度だと思いますね
結婚する場合は責任感があってほしいんですね
それから親のしつけにもありますし
だから 親がもうあまりにも我が子に執着して
もう可愛がってあげて
この社会人として育ててない場合は
ずっといつたっても親に甘えて生きたくなっちゃうんですね
だから結婚したくないっていうことにもなっちゃいますね
そういうふうに結構複雑になってくるんです
そのところでは それから仏教から言えば
人は結婚するかしないか
その人の自由だからね
放っておけっていうことなんです
それは仏教的には問題にならないんです
まあ現在 例えば日本の社会で結婚しない人っていうのはもうありすぎでしょ
それは社会的な問題であって
仏教的な問題じゃないんです
この社会で もうどんどんあまり勢いでもう年寄りばっかり増えちゃって
仕事できる人々がすごい少ない
その連中もものすごいわがまま育ちで
責任感がなくて ろくに仕事もできない
で 今日本は大震災でいろんなことで悩んでいるのに
ビシビシと誰も動かない
力がないんですね だから仕事をする人々はいるんだけど
今世界で負けているんですね
だからそこは社会の問題で
仏教的な問題じゃないんです
子育てが悪いんです 結局は
だから仏教もこれ言いますよ
いつでも子供の数が多い方が国が豊かだよと
これは豊かかないかっていうだけの問題で
国が豊かで衰えて欲しくないと思うならば
いつでも年寄りの人口よりは若い人口の方が多くなければいけないんです
年寄りの人口がどんどん増えるっていうことは
もうそれから滅びていくんです
ですから 社会のことを心配するならば
もうさっさと結婚した方がいいんです
これ 仏教の問題じゃないんです
仏教が言うのは 結婚というのは相当大変なことだと
ものすごい責任感が出てくるんだよと
だから人が結婚するかいしないかではなくて
あなたの人生を善行為のできる人生に入れ替えてくださいと仏教は人間に語るだけであって
そこら辺 仏教ははっきりと分け分けています
仏教の仕事と俗世間の仕事
これは政治家と日本人が考える考えるべき問題なんです
子供をたくさん産めるような環境を作るのは政治家だから
政府の国の仕事であって
社会の仕事でもありますしね
まあまあ そういうことなんですね
あまりパンチ力のある答えができないんですけど
ちょっと  お疲れ様です
他にいらっしゃいます
まだ時間ございます えっと
すいません 奥の方にいらっしゃいますけど
手を上げたまんまでいて
お願いします  私 人の子供を育てておりまして
小学生 なので とてもわんぱくだしで
本当に毎日私もね やっぱりあまり感情を爆発させないように
できるだけあまりひどく叱らないようにと思えば思うほど
腹の立つようなネタのことが多数喧嘩はするし
本当にうるさいし もう言うことを聞かないしで
本当にもうこう なかなか難しい状態です
それでそうですね あの
本当にこの自分であまりにも感情を抑えようとしすぎると
内心もっと怒りが増大するようになってまいりまして
それで何かこう 知覚的に子供をこう
子供の姿や声を意識的にちょっと拒絶するような感じになって
能面のような顔で仕事をしているように
義務だけを果たして あの
両親からは程遠いような状態で切り込らしているような時もありまして
どういうふうに 本当にこう
子育てをしている母親にとっては
なかなかこう 感情を 感情
理性を立たせて感情を抑えるということはなかなか難しいことのように感じていて
日々チャレンジして ほとんど敗北に終わるという
どうしてどういうふうにしていけば
そうですね まああの感情は捨てるんです
抑える必要ないんです
失敗するんです だから
あなたは自分の子供が失敗して欲しくないしね
もうしっかりと成長 成長してほしいしね
失敗するのは感情が割り込んでくる時なんですね
それはあの あんたもものすごい理屈っぽい人間になってみてください
何かギャーギャーと言うんじゃなくて
もうこれだからこうなるでしょ
これだからこうなるでしょ
だからこうこうでしょうとかね
ギャーギャーと理屈言ってください
例えばわんぱくの子なんて
あんた社会人としては失格ですねとかね
もう家族の中でも社会人として生きていられませんだからね
外に行ったら最悪でしょうとかね
親の話に耳を傾けない人には
もう世の中の人のことは聞こえないでしょうとかね
聞いたっても怖くておびえて聞くだけだけでしょうとかね
そういうふうに この理屈ばっかしで理屈で言うと
もう子供はあんまり何も言わなくなるんですね
感情でギャーギャーって言っちゃうと
もう子供は何も言わないんですけど
その時も 代わりにもうかなりもう何とかやっちゃうんです
結局はあなたも感情的になってくると
子供も感情的になって
お互い様感情爆発しちゃうんですね
ですから このむちゃくちゃもう理屈で理屈で
で 言ってみてください
言う時はね あんまりやんちゃやってることは外でやってくださいと
これは私の世界ですからね
家っていうのはお母さんの世界であると
お母さんが帝王だと みんな私の支配下にいなくちゃあかんかと
お父さんであろうか 誰であろうと
嫌ならはい 出て行ってくださいと
それはほとんど毎日のように言っているんですけど
自分でちょっと冷酷な母親なのではないかと思って
時々反省したりしてたんですけど
それはそれで  それはそれでいいんです
これ あなたがこの感情がありがたいと思っているんだから
そうなってるんです 冷酷でいいんです
冷酷ではなくて これ理性ということなんですね
言っていることが論理に合ってるならば OK です
で 私は結構そこ同じアドバイスでうまくいってるケース
結構ありますよ 日本でもある女性がね
なんか周りにもいろんなこと言われるんだから
もう自分でもいろんなことやりたいんですけど
ずっと子供に愛情をいっぱい注いで育てなくちゃいけないんだけど
なかなかやりきれないとかね
あれやこれやと言ってました
あのね この感情でやる必要はないんだと
子供はあなた一人のものじゃないんだからね
みんなに仕事を分担させてくださいと
お母さんにも責任があって
お父さんにも一部責任があって
おばあさんにはおばあさんの分担があって
それみんなに分かってあげてくださいと
仕事は あなた産んだんだから
その仕事を分担してあげることはあなたの責任だよと
だから あんたどこかでなんか仕事やっていきたければ
お父さんが家にいるんだからね
お父さん じゃあはい 頼みましょうと
言って さっさと出て行ってくださいと
子供放っておいて それでお父さんが子供を無視することできませんだからね
びっしり育ちますよ その間で
お母さん帰ってくるまで
だからそういう風に言ったことがありまして
今思い出したんだから言まったけどね
それからうまくいったんです
それからお父さんもなんか自分にも責任があるんだっていうことで
えらいもう気分がよく
調子に乗って気分いい気分になって
で 子供がやんちゃやってる時は
まあお母さんはなんか何も言えない場合はお父さんが言ったりする
お父さんが言ったらダメな場合はお母さんが言ったりして
結構うまくやっているんです
そういうことで まあそれは理性でやっているんでしょ
冷酷じゃないんで それ言ったらお母さんもそんなこと言ったらなんか冷酷で冷たい人間だって言われるだろうと
そんなことはない 気にするな
そんなことはと こんなことも母の責任やというのは
それが残酷でしょうにと
残酷よりは冷酷の方がいいんじゃないんですか
冷酷であっても残酷じゃないんだからね
だから自分が家の中では自分が帝王女王という感じでね
でではしかし論理的にね
これでこれでみんなに仕事を分担させて
このやんちゃな人にも何か仕事をあげてください
これこれやってくださいと
で いくらなんでもこれ買い物を頼んだりとか
いろいろ何か考えてください
で 洗濯物持ってこいとかね
何もお前 息子を呼んであの洗濯物落ちちゃったの
ちょっと持ってこいよ
お母さん今忙しいんだからとかね
そんな風にすごい冷静に言うんです
嫌だと言ったらもうもっと攻撃するんで
あんたもう社会人じゃないんだけど
口調は冷静なんですけど
内心かなり怒りが怒りが大きくなっているような時があって
最終的には爆発したりとかするので
それはどういうふうに自分を
内心のことは瞑想でもしないと
内心の怒りが表に出ますからね
だからあなたの冷静さっていうのは
そんなに冷静じゃないと思いますよ
内心怒りがあるんだからね
先に内心の怒りを消してください
難しいので もう日々チャレンジして
これ怒りに慣れすぎ うん
これで失敗するんだからね
だからプライド持ってください
失敗はしたくないというふうにね
失敗はしたくないと プライド持っちゃえば
もう内心の怒りがなくなります
内心の怒りが失敗のもとなんですよ
将棋で自分が間違った駒を動かしちゃうんです
怒りがあると これが正しいと判断するでしょ
その駒を動かしてはいけないんです
失敗するんですね 負けちゃいます
だから失敗したくないとプライド持っちゃうと
まあ内心の怒りが消えると思います
内心の怒りがない人にとっては
どんな厳しいことも言えます
何のこともなく だから皆様方は子供を怒鳴りたいんだけど
もうどうしようかと言葉に悩んだりするんです
その場合は怒りがあるんです
私はガクンと怒鳴る場合は全くも怒ってないんです
内心ニッコニッコと笑ってるんです
その時は結構言葉出てくるんです
だってこれはもうネタを作るような感じですからね
その時むちゃくちゃなことを言う
です でも すごい怒鳴りの言葉を言っても怒ってない場合は
聞いてる人々もなんか漫才聞いたような感じで楽しいんですけど
しかし話は聞いてるんです
だから子供を怒りたいければ怒ってもいいんだけど
怒りで怒ってはならんです
だから それは変な矛盾な話ですけど
あの  ちょっとしっかりと言っちゃうとかね
ガクンと言うとかね それは構わない
やめなさいとかね やめなさいというと
怒りが入っているとダメなんです
一言目は怒りが入っていないかもしれません
ん？ 一言目 二言目になってくるとだんだん入ってきます
ちょっと聞き取れない
一言目 一回目 一回目の時にはあんまり怒りも入ってないんですけど
二回 三回 四回と言うようになると
だんだん怒りが増大してきます
どうしても言うことが聞かない場合はね
その連中が存在をしないことにしてください
自宅に入れないで  きれいさっぱり無視してください
それでもいい  いいんです
いいんです 例えば 料理を用意している場合は
そいつらの分も用意しないことにする
台所にご飯あるんだけど
わざと皿とかなんとかしないことにする
それでいきなりまたお母さん
私ね あんたあれ言ったことやってないでしょうにと
だからあなたはこの家にいない人間よと
この攻撃方法は私が結構やられましたよ
小さい時 あんたそんなことやるならば
今日はご飯はなしと それで結構怖くなるんです
なんか母親が今日ご飯あげれませんと言った途端
なんか微妙に怖くなるんです
その手もいつも使ってる
ん？ この手もいつも使ってるんですけども
なかなか良くなりません
まあ実行してないでしょ
あんた言ってるだけで
いえ あの かなりする方なんですけども
最終的に折れて育てています
かなり厳しくしてもなかなか汚い子供たちでへこんでいます
いろいろ性格的なこともあるかもしれませんだけどね
まあ性格を理解してくださいませね
他人だからね 子供もね
その性格を理解していれば
どう躾すればいいかと見えてきますよ
まあ虎だと思ったらどうですかね
まあ虎を捕まえて育てているんだと
だから虎に攻撃されても食べられますからね
それなりに だから我々いろいろ動物飼って
ちゃんと面倒見る場合あるでしょ
その場合 その動物の性格を見て餌をあげたり
いろんな面倒を見てあげるんで
で 生活にぴったしはめると
動物たちはこちら違う動物なんですけど
親しくしてくれるんです
だから子供たちも結局は人間の中の他人ですから
自分たちの性格がありますから
これはかなり野性的で乱暴かもしれませんし
あるいはもうあんた母親で見るんだからダメよと見るんであって
普通に見れば ただまあどちらでもある普通かもしれませんしね
だからまあ 世の中のどこにでもいる
まあ決まってるパターンの子供やっていう感じで見るならばね
みんな決まってるパターンでやってますよ
やんちゃ連中に私はこれ読んで
あんた方面白くないんだよって
やんちゃやってる だってみんな決まってるパターンでやってますからね
その年になったらこうやったりこうやったり
こういうことやったり
みんなやってますよと
あんま面白くないとか
そうすると自分たちもこのなんか遺伝的にもう反応でやってるんだっていうことをどんどん理解するんです
とにかく子供の性格も理解して
で こんな性格はどのように直せばいいかっていう風にも勉強したりしてください
あの 研究してください
研究っていうのは 外をいろいろ本を読むことじゃなくて
子供が研究対象なんですね
で 研究対象にしてちゃんと見てみると見えてくると思います
で 効かないということはまだ通じてないってことなんです
歯磨きの話出したでしょ
だから親の理論というのは虫歯になるんだぞと
だからただ我が子は歯を磨いて健康的にいたいと親の感情だけで
これは子供は聞いてくれないんですね
それで理屈を言おうかなといって
虫歯の話を持ってくる
これあまり古すぎ 虫歯の話は
虫歯の脅しはあまりも古すぎ
現代科学医学には合わないんです
それで私が最新医学的な話を言ったところで
一発で終わり 話は だからまだこのあなたの言語を向こうに通じてないんですね
同じ日本語喋ってますけど
向こうの思考パターンとこちらの思考パターンというのはかみ合ってない場合があります
だからこの私みたいに
私はもう頭の中ネタばっかしだからね
誰も笑ってくれませんだけどね
もう それぞれ人は別な言語を喋っていると思っているんです
だから言うことを論理的に言うことを理解しなかったら
個別のこちらの言語はないんだと
時々子供たちもギャーギャーギャーといろんなことを私に言う場合は
よくわからない時もよくありますよ
私は何のこともなく あのね
この火星人の火星語で喋ってもわかりませんだからね
何のこともなく言うんです
あんた火星語だからね
日本語で言ってくれないのかということで
まあだからそこは私はただ遊んでいるだけなんですけど
当然子供が言ったことはわかる
それで大人にお母さんに聞くのは
今何言ってるのかと そういうことで
あの ただ言ったことを理解してくれると思ったら
それはないと思いますよ
言語が違う こちらフランス語で喋って
向こうはドイツ語だったらもうわかるわけないでしょう
そこら辺も一つ親の仕事なんです
子供の言語を発見すること
まあ言語を教えるも親だからね
親が言葉を教える時はどう教えたかっていうね
まあまあありますけど
とにかくまあまあ感情やらね
自分の思考とかありますからね
ですから まあ子供の言語を理解する
理解して そちらに理解できる言語で喋れば
もう一回で聞きます 性格も気にしなくちゃいけない
時々一回で聞く子供もいて
2 3回言ったら聞いてくれる子供もいて
そっちを思い出さなくちゃやらない連中もいて
落とさなきゃやらない性格もいるしね
あるいは逆に言ったらダメな子もいるんです
そういう子供 日本で私が知ってます
親が何も言ったらダメなんです
しかし 自分で全部考えてビシビシともう育てているんです
でもただ見守っていれば十分です
そういう性格の子も生まれて便利ですけど
その子供だったらね 自分で全部判断してうまく成長するならば
自分で勉強して 自分で歩みして全部やるならば
それは便利なんですけど
まあそれはわからないんですね
まあとにかく 業によって回ってくる子が
自分にも業の関係があるんですね
だから自分もそのいろんな勉強をしなくちゃいけないんです
子供を通して だから子供はある面ではまあ教えているんです
いろんなこと 子供の教え方は
なんかすごい逆の教え方なんですね
あなた落ち着きなさいということを子供は言えませんだから
その代わりにイライラすることばっかりするんです
で 母親がイライラするんですね
あ こいつはいつでも私がイライラすることばっかりやってますから
その点では私が落ち着きを研究します
訓練しますよということで
自分の勉強にもなります
子供から結構勉強できますよ
ものすごい勉強できます
そういうふうなことで
このまあ この怒ったりする暇がないんです
感情にやられる暇がないんです
結構ありますよ 研究するところは
そういうことでやってみてください
一気に成功しなくたってもいいんだからね
上の子は年生でまだ子供ですけれども
ちょうどのお話をぜひ聞きたいと申ししておりますので
できましたら共有会を作っていただけますでしょうか
お願いいたします  はい
ありがとうございました
そろそろ時間がだいぶ過ぎてしまったので
よろしければこれで質疑応答時間を終了したいと思います
それでは最後に皆さんで回向の文を唱えて終了したいと思います
合掌してください 回向の仏法僧の三宝に礼拝敬し
戒を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに廻向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱を得られますように
サッビーティホイワンジャントーサッブロブイナッスドゥ
マーテーバワットワンテラーヨスキーディーダユコバババトゥサッブマンガランラッカントゥサッブデヴァタサッブブッダヌーバヴェーナサッブダンマヌーバヴェーナサッブサンガーヌーバーヴェーナサダー
スッティバワントゥテーアーユラーローギヤサンパッティサンガサンパッティメーウェーチャアトー ニッバーナサンパッティミナーテーサミッジャトゥ
はい ではどうもありがとうございました
ありがとうございます